This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. The new Red Bull Dragonberry and Tropic Berry Energizers, now at McDonald's, made with freeze-dried fruit and an electric burst of flavor. The all-new Red Bull Energizers, now at McDonald's. This product may not be right for you. High in caffeine, details of McDonald's.com. At participating Canadian restaurants excluding Quebec.
Hey, this is Hayes Davenport. And Sean Clements. We host the podcast, Hollywood Handbook. Every episode we're trying to help our guests improve their careers by mainly focusing on how they can help us improve our careers. The show's famously super accessible so you can easily jump into any of our 650 episodes and understand what's going on. We recommend some of our recent episodes with Ben Stiller, Danny McBride, Riz Ahmed, and Mary Steenberg. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Nick Terturo. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, the longest yard, or Spike Lease Black Klansman.
And on my new podcast, Delivering Happiness with Nick Tatoro, I deliver pizza to a new guest. I've shared a slice with everyone from Seth Rollins. What are you doing, my belt? To Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am. And now, we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Tuturo.
It's called Happiness, Delivering Happiness. And many, many more. Open your free High Heart Radio app. Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Tutro. And listen now. I'm Hoda Kotopi, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotvey. You know, I'm always searching for inspiration and useful tools to maximize joy. Like when my friend Henry Winkler offered advice to aspiring actors and really anybody hoping to stand out.
You're not hired just to fill time and space. You're hired to fill the space with you. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Our hometown is not a test tube. 90 miles northeast of Nashville, a battle for the future of America, plays out in one small town. Developers with right-wing ties
have purchased hundreds of acres of land. We need cities on a shining hill. This is Our Town, a podcast about what happens when a small town becomes the site of a social experiment and fights back. Guess you didn't move in on a bunch of dumb hillbillies now, did you? Listen to Our Town
on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. today, we are doing an episode that selfishly, I think I need more than anything right now.
And on a topic which I have searched, I have looked, there aren't really, or there are very few in-depth podcast episodes about it. We are talking about the psychology of PCOS, PMOS, as it's now called. Kind of to begin the episode with a little bit of a story time, I was diagnosed with PMOS last year. And I think just since then I found that the information and the advice and the help I've been looking for has been very, very lacking. And I know I'm not alone in this. It can take years for our symptoms to be recognized to finally get a diagnosis. And even afterwards, the advice we usually get is come back when you want to get pregnant, go on the pill, do some exercise.
What is often not examined is the impact of this dismissal on our psychology and the impact that PMS has on our mental health, our emotional health, as well as the physical symptoms. Something I know would have helped me would have just been sitting down with an expert and just getting to ask a lot of why questions. Why was this happening? Why did this start? Why does my body behave this way? Why are certain treatment options offered in others are not? So today, we're just going to create that opportunity for others. I have in the studio, Dr. Hazel Wallace. She is a female health specialist, a doctor, a nutritionist, the author of Not Just a Period. She has spent thousands of hours, probably more, thinking about studying, examining women's hormones, women's health, women's nutrition, PMOS symptoms.
She also has PMOS herself, so she really knows the ups and downs. We are so excited to have her. Dr. Hazel Wallace, welcome to the psychology of your 20s. Thank you for having me. Do you find the intro is a little bit awkward, as I was saying? Yeah, I always do. I always do. It's hard to know how to respond, but I think you captured everything, so thank you very much. Okay, I'm so glad. Well, I've done the introduction, but I'm going to let you do your own as well. Who are you? What's the work that kind of lights your fire? What do people know you as? Or who do people know you as?
So in terms of who I am and how I got into this work, it is quite a long and winding story, but I'll try to summarize it quite short for you. So my backstory is when I was 14, I lost my father to a stroke. And being a 14-year-old girl, that was really significant in my life. And I think that moment made me first want to be a doctor. And second of all, It helped me realize that our lifestyle, including nutrition, plays a really big impact on our health. So those two things started to shape what came next. So I went into medicine and I was really excited to learn everything there is about nutrition. Doctors don't learn really anything about nutrition. And I was a bit disappointed by that and also quite shocked because from my own reading,
I was understanding that nutrition was hugely impactful on our health and preventing. disease. So I started a blog and Instagram page 14 years ago now, which is crazy because I'm like a dinosaur in the industry, called the Food Medic, really trying to like connect medicine and nutrition. And that was what I did for a really long time. The Food Medic page still exists today. And I've written books on nutrition. But along my journey as a doctor, I was working through the pandemic as a COVID doctor, which was a really challenging time. And I was living alone. So outside of my hospital hours, I spent a lot of time reading. And I was reading a lot about how women were neglected in health and healthcare, how most of the medical research we have is based on men
or male cells, male mice. And that a lot of what we know about women is just kind of left up to guesswork, which means women's health is hugely neglected. I found that insane and really in raging as a woman and also as a doctor with many female patients. So I wrote a book on it called The Female Factor. And since then, which was around 2020, I completely pivoted my work into women's health because there is so much work to be done. And I think also, as you mentioned, I also was going through my own diagnosis or diagnosis journey with PMOS. Despite being a doctor, it took me two years from first going to my doctor to actually getting the diagnosis because I was told that I just didn't fit the picture. There was no need to kind of progress with further testing. And I think
being a junior doctor at the time, I didn't want to, I don't know, step on anyone's toes who was more senior than I was in that space. So fast forward to 2025 last year I released my second women's health book, not just a period. And that is basically your encyclopedia to the menstrual cycle in terms of not just the hormones and everything that happens across the phases, but how that impacts your skin, your mood, your nutrition, your exercise, even your libido. And for me, that was really a really empowering book to write because I learned so much about myself. But also, I feel like it's something that every woman should know. I'm just like listening to you being just nodding my head.
Just being like, yeah, yeah, exactly. What I find so interesting about that story and there's so many things, like you speaking about your dad and how you've had this like powerful, motivated to change people's lives and completely pivoting. Part of what I found really interesting as well was you talking about how you were a doctor looking for a diagnosis and it took you two years. Yeah. And if that is not the most insane but also perfect metaphor example for what it's like to get help as a woman, I really don't know what is.
Yeah. So today we're going to talk about PMOS and you went after your own diagnosis. You got one and so many other women that I know are currently like at some stage in that process. can you give us a quick overview of what PMOS is, formally PCOS, maybe also like touching on the significance of that name change because that happened very recently, like three months ago. Three weeks ago, wow, my gosh, so, so that has happened very recently. Okay, talk us through it. So there are a lot of letters and a lot of words, but I will break it down. So formerly called PCOS, polycystic ovary syndrome, has been renamed to PMOS, which stands for polyendocrine, metabolic ovarian syndrome. Like, breaking down that name in itself, I think is really important.
Polyendocrine, poly means many, endocrine means hormones, many hormones are involved. We often talk about testosterone when it comes to PCOS or PMOS, but there's many hormone systems involved. metabolic signifies that it's not just your ovaries, it's your metabolic health. So what I mean by that is like your blood sugar balance, insulin resistance, cardiovascular risk, ovarian highlights that your ovaries and your reproductive system are still involved. They're still a very important part of the diagnosis. And then syndrome means that there's many different symptoms and signs. There's not one cause.
So it's kind of like many things together. And the reason why the name change is really important, first of all, it's so rare to change a name in medicine. Like that in itself is huge. But it came about because so many patients and practitioners were like, PCS is so misleading and it's confusing. Because polycystic ovary syndrome kind of focuses just on the ovaries. And it makes us assume that you have to have polycystic ovaries to have the condition which you don't. And also that it's just an ovary problem. But now we know it's a full body condition. So this new name change, I think, pivots away from, this is just a problem with your ovaries. And actually, this is a full body condition. You don't have to have polycystic ovaries to have the condition. Some women do. But it's not essential for the diagnosis. So I think that in itself is really important because a lot of people were only getting the diagnosis if they had kind of picture on their ultrasound. So by changing it, we're opening up the definition and it means a lot more
women are fitting that criteria. And I think thinking back to my own diagnosis, I was told, you don't fit the picture of PCS. So you can't have it because I wasn't fitting that very tight definition that they had in their textbook. Whereas now we know it's much more than that. So that is something I did not know, which was that previous. obviously, as you're kind of telling us, only if you had cysts on your ovaries, would they say yes, you can kind of enter the gate? Is that what you were saying? And if you didn't, they were like, well, something else is wrong with you and I'm going to assume they weren't going to look any further. Is that one I'm, am I right in assuming? Yeah, you're right in saying that. I mean, to be diagnosed with PMOS or PCOS, there are three criteria and you need to have two of three. Oh, okay. One of them is polycystic morphology. So these cysts on your ovaries, They're different to the cysts that we talk about when we say you've got a cyst on your ovary and it's ruptured. These are immature follicles that have not kind of developed fully and they look what we call like a string of pearls on your ovary. So having one of those can be diagnostic. The other two features are having raised testosterone and this can be on a blood test, or it can be clinical features of it. So clinical features of raised testosterone would be excess hair around your jaw line, and this can be on a blood test, or it can be clinical features of it. So clinical features of raised testosterone would be excess hair around your jawline. your face, your neck, your chest, typical male pattern or acne or hair loss from kind of male patterns on the forehead or on the scalp. And the third feature is absent or regular periods.
So you have to have two or three of those. So technically, you don't need to have the polycystic ovaries. But I think for a lot of people, that was an area that was causing confusion. But also, even if you you've got the diagnosis, so you've been fighting for your diagnosis, you got it. A lot of women were then told, we'll just come back when you want to get pregnant, because it's just no very problem. Or take the pill and that will sort you out. And I'm not saying the pill is a bad solution. I know we're going to talk about that later.
But I think the problem is we were completely neglecting that women were really struggling with the fatigue, the difficulty losing weight, the metabolic features, the cravings, the blood sugar crashes, the excess hair growth, the cystic acne, and just telling her to go away and come back when she wants to get pregnant. And it's so wild to me because I was given that exact quote, whenever I say it online, where I hear it repeated back to be by thousands of women. I'm not going to lie.
Somebody said that to me last week. I'm not even joking. I had a gynecology appointment. Last week, I had to go private because I'm, I'm in the UK, but like the waitless was too long. I was having really terrible problems. I couldn't get to go and see a public, you know, a GP. Well, I have a GP, but they, she basically was like, the referral process was so difficult.
She was like, well, if you have the means go private. And I went and I was like, I have never gone to a private doctor before in Australia. It's very rare. And I was like expecting her. I was like, oh my gosh, I'm so, I was excited. I'm so excited. I feel like she's going to have something for me. And she told me to exercise, which I was like, well, I already do that.
And then was like, oh, but your blood pressure, like your heart rate's really low. You have like brachocardia. And I was like, oh, because I exercise. So we can rule that. Thank you for the advice. We can rule that one out. And then she was like, you have a partner. And I was like, yeah, I do.
And she goes, are you guys trying to have kids? And I was like, no, no, no. And she kind of looked at me like, why are you here? And then she was like, oh, well, and then at the end was like, you know, we'd be really worried if you're like trying to get pregnant, but you're not. So we kind of have some time. And I left and I actually was like very teary and very upset about it. And something that my boyfriend actually said was like, that advice is inappropriate, a, like just because you should still get treatment. But what if you just didn't want kids? Yes. And I'm sure that's something you see all the time where it's like, wait, so if I don't want to. children, this isn't going to be dealt with as a bad way of saying, but managed. And yet you're saying, and I know from experience, I'm sure many women listening to this, know from experience, there is like a laundry list of other stuff that is going on. You've mentioned three. Well, actually, you've mentioned quite a few. But can you give us some others that might have nothing to do with
your period or nothing to do with, you know, reproductive health? Yeah, I think the most kind of visible ones and for a lot of people can be almost the most distressing is the visible features and that is cystic acne and also haircitism, which is hair growth in unwanted places. And it's typically around like the jaw line and the cheeks and the neck and the chest. And it can be quite stubborn. And even on fair-skinned women who typically wouldn't have dark hair, it can be very dark and difficult. to get on top of. The other symptoms will be things like gaining weight or difficulty losing weight. Anxiety and depression is very common. There's a higher risk in women who have PMOS. So that's something that's often not spoken about. The fertility issues, of course. And then insulin resistance
has a huge trigger for the condition, but also that can cause symptoms in itself with blood sugar crashes, fatigue, and, you know, is a really core thing that we need to be focusing on. So I find it really difficult when you tell me that you've gone to see someone. And just that conversation didn't happen because that carries its own risk factors of future type 2 diabetes, cardiovascular disease, which women with PMOS unfortunately have much higher risk of. So it's so important that every woman who comes through the door with a new diagnosis of PMOS is being screened. It's in our guidelines, we need to be checking blood sugar. We need to be checking cholesterol, blood pressure. That needs to be done. I would say, like, majority of the time, that's not
happening from what I'm seeing. Well, yeah, I didn't get any of that, but that's interesting. Maybe I'll ask for a follow-up appointment. Please do. The new Red Bull, Dragonberry and Tropicberry energizers now at McDonald's, made with freeze-dried fruit and an electric burst of flavor. The all-new Red Bull Energizers. Now at McDonald's. This product may not be right for you. High in caffeine, details at McDonald's.ca.
At participating Canadian restaurants, excluding Quebec. Hey, this is Hayes-Davenport. And Sean Clements. We host the podcast, Hollywood Handbook. Every episode we're trying to help our guests improve their careers by mainly focusing on how they can help us improve our careers. The show is famously super accessible, so you can easily jump into any of our 650 episodes
and understand what's going on. We recommend some of our recent episodes with Ben Stillard. The definition of what is a movie has kind of changed anywhere, too, right? What do you think it is now? It's images and words being spoken, captured by some sort of technology. Danny McBride. He loves Mawba. Oh, that's fantastic.
And you make it on, you make your own. That's great. I call him Terro Reed. It's a good name. They're all named after cast members of American Pie. Yeah. I call, I don't, I never looked up if she was a. in this, but I call him Leachie Sobieski.
I don't think she was an American pie, but I still like that. I haven't looked it up. She was prominent around the same time. Then Mary Steenberg. Why are you guys talking to me? I'm worried. Why are you talking so down to me that you think I don't understand your little
play game? I just really I get it. I'm trying to set you up for success here. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the I Heart Radio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Nick Titoro. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, the longest yard, or Spike Lee's Black Klansman. But I'm also from Queens, which means I know pizza.
And on my new podcast, delivering happiness with Nick Toto, I deliver pizza from Prince Street Pizza to a new guest. Are you delivering pizza now? Then we sit down for a real conversation. I've shared a slice with everyone from Seth Rollins. What are you doing my belt? To Alex Rodriguez. Just to let you people know, we're talking to one of the goats here.
To Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so excited. Exactly out of their mind as I am. And now we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Tituro. It's called Happiness. Delivering Happiness. Mariano Rivera. Oh, my God.
And many, many more. Open your free High Heart Radio app. Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Totoro. And listen now. I'm Hoda Kotbby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb. If you know me, you know, I'm always searching for inspiration and useful tools to maximize joy. So this podcast lets us uncover those things together through meaningful conversations with fascinating people. Like when my friend Henry Winkler offered advice to aspiring actors and really anybody hoping to
stand out. You're not hired just to fill time and space. You're hired to fill the space with you. You have something in your guts. You go with it. And Sean Johnson recalled the moment she realized her now husband, Andrew, was the one. He was just so unapologetically himself and knew nothing of Hollywood. He hadn't been on a plane before without his family. It was so pure. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Our town is small taters by most standards, right? But to the people who grew up here, it's everything. What happens when a quiet Tennessee town becomes the front line in the city. a battle over the future of America. Developers with right-wing ties have purchased hundreds of acres of land in the area. The first thing you see when it pops up is pioneers in Appalachia. But they weren't just planning houses. We need cities on a shining hill that exemplify and embody the Christian way of life.
Stop right there. Is that normal? A podcast about what happens when a small town becomes the site of a social experiment. God need men to rule. Great. And decides to fight back. Do not use my hard work to sell your bull. They're not just opposing what's being planned for here. Our hometown is not a test tube.
They feel like they're standing in opposition to an entire administration. Guess you didn't move in on a bunch of dumb hillbillies now, did you? Listen to Our Town on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So what I'm always wanted to know, and something that I feel like nobody's explained to me, is What is actually happening in my body, hormonally, on a cellular level, scientifically, that is creating this? So you spoke about this kind of, for some women, it's like this string of pearl. I'm not sure if you said underdeveloped or overdeveloped follicles, like in the ovary. Yeah.
Is that what it is? Or like, how does this start? Where does it come from? It's a great question. And in terms of what causes PMOS? The short answer is we don't know, but it's likely to be a combination of genetics, environmental, and lifestyle factors. So a combination of things. But what's happening in your body, first of all, can kind of vary from person to person.
And the other thing to mention is PMOS and how it presents in a different woman can be so different to the woman next to her. It can kind of appear very differently. But the main thing to say is it's not one single hormone that's causing this. and it's not one single organ, think of it as like a network problem where the ovaries, the brain, and your metabolism are just not really communicating in the way that they should. So all our hormone systems in our bodies do not work in isolation. They all communicate with one another. And when one of them is out of, we'll say balance for lack of a better word, but if it's out
of sync, it impacts everything downstream. And so in the case of PMOS, there's a few things that can be going on. First of all, the brain can be sending signals to the ovaries, which is normal, but it can be sending too many, which can stimulate the production of androgens, which are male hormones. The one that we often talk about is testosterone. Now, it's normal for women to produce a little bit of testosterone. That's good. Lots of testosterone can be problematic because it can interfere with ovulation.
which means the follicles, which are going to be eggs, don't fully mature. And that's why women with PMOS don't ovulate every month and have long cycles. So that's the first thing. Now, the other big component is insulin resistance. 80% of women have insulin resistance regardless of their BMI or body weight. Insulin resistance means that our body isn't responding as well to insulin when we have carbohydrates. And so it has to produce more insulin. High levels of insulin and dysregulated blood sugar have a knock on effect by also increasing
things like androgens, testosterone. They can also directly impact the ovaries. All of this is like a huge cascade of things that cause us to have longer cycle length, higher testosterone, which impacts things like ovulation, but also those symptoms we mentioned acne, hair growth. and the insulin resistance is impacting, first of all, our risk of those future illnesses that I mentioned conditions, but also our blood sugar balance, our cravings, our ability to lose weight. So it's multiple things happening at once, which is really confusing and hard to disentangle. And some women will be more impacted by one part of that pathway than others. So you might find that you actually don't really get terrible androgenic, those kind of acne, hair-related symptoms, but you're impacted by other things.
And so we treat all women with PMOS the same, but I think what we're starting to see in the research is that there's probably different types of PMOS going on. We can't neatly categorize them yet, but I suspect that in the future that we'll have very personalized treatments for different types of PMOS because it behaves so differently in different women. That is so interesting because, and again, I keep relating this back to my personal experience, but again, at the top of the episode, I'll let them know, I told them. I'm like, I'm here just to ask you questions for my own sake in a way, but I would go online and be like, okay, PMS back then when I was really looking for, it was PCOS, like, PMOS, like, really heavy period. PMS, like, I've had my period for like four months, TMI to the gang listen.
But like, you know, PMOs like this, this, this. And it would be PMSS is the lack of a period. PMS is this and this. And I was like, but I don't have those things. And a big thing that really confused me was I was like, but I don't have acne. And I don't really grow hair in other places. And I don't, I get, I have the opposite problem. Like, I like, my period doesn't cease. And what you're saying is as the research is progressing, you think that we're going to start categorizing it, maybe the same way that we like categorize diabetes in some ways, or maybe the same way that we even categorize certain like neurological disorders. Is that kind of what you're seeing happening? Yeah, I think like we can, if you think of it like a then diagram, this is how I
see it in my head with like four circles and in the, in the middle there's like where they all overlap and someone might have all of these features. And that's one type. And then, Someone might have two of those features. They may have, you know, the irregular cycles and the acne. Or they may have normal cycles and really bad hearsitism and acne. Or they might just have fertility struggles and they've only realized that they've got PMOS because they've been on that journey. So it seems that there is different phenotypes or types of PMOS.
The reason I'm really cautious with this is I've seen that idea kind of being captured and spat out on social media in various different forms and it's not always accurate so I think like at this point if someone's telling you you need this specific type of treatment for this specific type of PMOS we don't we clinically don't use that terminology yet
but I think it will be I think it's really useful for women who have PMOS to understand what are what is their problematic features what is really concerning for them so they can articulate that when they're speaking to their doctor and ask for support in those areas. Because I think that's where maybe we are really ladding down women. I really want to touch on something you just said,
which is you see this idea online a lot. Yes. This idea of the four different phenotypes categories, strains, whatever you want to call it. And I've seen that. And I was going to ask you, I was like, what are the four different types? And it's so interesting because I think this is a pattern with a lot of health conditions that primarily, if not exclusively, impact women. You're not getting the information from probably your GP. You're not getting the information even from the specialist that you need. And so you turn online, turn to like online resources. And this is a whole different conversation, but the amount of misinformation you're saying is kind of spreading through those channels because like there is no consensus on this.
这也是你经常在网上看到的说法。是的。关于这四种不同表型、类别、种类，随便你怎么叫它的这种观点。我见过这种说法。我本来想问你，我想知道这四种不同的类型是什么？这非常有趣，因为我认为这是很多主要（如果不是全部的话）影响女性的健康状况的一个共同模式。你可能无法从你的全科医生那里获得信息。你甚至无法从你需要专科医生那里获得信息。于是你求助于网络，求助于网络资源。这是一个完全不同的话题，但通过这些渠道传播的虚假信息量是非常惊人的，因为对此并没有达成共识。
Yeah, that's it. And I think that's so reflective of every area of women's health. If you feel like you aren't getting the help from your normal healthcare provider, women turn to social media. And if you see someone who has something similar to you, then you're going to see what are you doing that's helping you. Or you see someone who's got a stethoscope around their neck and they're on social media and they've got a page. You're going to listen to them. and I mean I am health professional who also creates content and has done for years but I really I think you have to approach anyone who's giving healthcare advice on a specific condition
是的，就是这样。我认为这非常能反映女性健康的各个领域。如果你觉得自己没有从常规医疗保健提供者那里获得帮助，女性就会求助于社交媒体。如果你看到有人有和你类似的情况，那么你就会去看看他们在做什么，是什么在帮助他们。或者你看到一个脖子上挂着听诊器的人，他们在社交媒体上并且有一个主页。你会听他们的。我的意思是，我是一名健康专业人士，我也创作内容，而且已经创作多年了，但我真的认为，对于任何在特定情况下提供医疗建议的人，你都必须
with a lot of skepticism because just because someone has a doctor title or healthcare title doesn't mean that they're a specialist in that area and I guess that's the world world west of social media because it can be amazing to connect communities. It can be amazing to sometimes get support. And I think that's great, but also it's just so unfortunate that there is, it's a very muddy place to get health information and it's never going to be personalized to you. And I guess what I'm trying to say is that when it comes to PMOS and I have a, I work in a clinic and I see a lot of PMS women. And I would say no two women are getting the same pieces of advice. You know, everyone's getting such specific advice based on their goals, based on their symptoms, based on their
抱有很大的怀疑态度，因为仅仅因为某人有医生头衔或医疗头衔并不意味着他们就是该领域的专家。我想这就是社交媒体的蛮荒西部，因为它对于连接社群来说太棒了。它有时对于获得支持来说太棒了。我认为这很好，但同样非常不幸的是，这是一个非常浑浊的地方，很难获得健康信息，而且它永远不会针对你进行个性化定制。我想说的是，当谈到多囊卵巢综合征（PCOS）时，我在一家诊所工作，我见过很多患有PCOS的女性。我想说，没有两个女性会得到完全相同的建议。你知道，每个人都会根据自己的目标、症状、
diets, based on, you know, so many different things. Yeah. I relate to this. I've spent many a night on a Reddit thread. And I've also spent a lot of time on social media being like, well, this person looks like they know what they're talking about. And as somebody who also operates in that space, I think a big red flag is if somebody does not at something. stage say, this is general advice? Or doesn't it some stage say, I am not your doctor, I am not your therapist, go and this is where you can go and find it? And that's like a big thing that I always try and do is we have it in every single episode description. We say at the top of every single episode, you know, like I cannot provide you with individual kind of feedback or help.
饮食等许多不同的因素，得到非常具体的建议。是的。我对此深有同感。我曾在Reddit的帖子中度过许多个夜晚。我也花了很多时间在社交媒体上，心想，“嗯，这个人看起来很懂的样子”。作为一个也在那个领域运营的人，我认为一个巨大的红旗信号是，如果某人在某个阶段没有说：“这是普遍建议？”或者在某个阶段没有说：“我不是你的医生，我不是你的治疗师，去这里你可以找到这些？”这是我总是努力去做的一件大事，我们在每一集的简介中都有写。我们在每一集的开头都会说，你知道，比如我无法为你提供个人的反馈或帮助。
Yes. And I think that's a big red flag if you have somebody who's like, I'm going to give you the cure all. Yes. I'm going to tell you the final secret on this. It's going to fix your life. It's like, no. No, that's so true. I think you're looking for disclaimers and caveats and no one's selling you this magic bullet because
是的。如果你遇到那种说“我要给你包治百病”的人，我认为这是一个巨大的红旗。是的。我要告诉你关于这个的终极秘密。它会拯救你的生活。这就像，不。不，这太对了。我认为你在寻找免责声明和注意事项，没有人向你兜售这种灵丹妙药，因为
they just don't exist. Like, unfortunately, they don't. And you're looking for research. Yes. If somebody's, make sure they're starting sources. Yeah. And check the sources. Absolutely.
它们根本不存在。不幸的是，它们确实不存在。你在寻找研究。是的。如果有人这样做，确保他们提供了来源。是的。并核对来源。绝对是这样。
Sometimes somebody we, I actually had this happening the day where I was like, this source is amazing. And it was like a blog post. written by the person who was doing a video and I was like, I just got chipped. I was like, that is such great advice. And I was like, oh, that's an opinion. That's like not even real. Anyways, I kind of want to circle back to something because I flew over it too quickly,
有时我们……我其实今天刚遇到这种情况，当时我想：“这个来源太棒了。”结果那是一篇博客文章，是由做视频的那个人写的，当时我想：“我被骗了。”我心想：“这建议太棒了。”然后我想：“哦，那是个观点。那甚至都不是真实的。”无论如何，我还是想回到刚才的一个话题，因为我刚才一带而过了，
which is you mentioned the increased chances or likelihood or prevalence, I guess, of anxiety and depression and a myriad of other mental health concerns in women and people with PMOS. why is that? Is it purely because they are experiencing a medical issue that is being dismissed? So is it contextual? Is it environmental? Or is it biological or social? Why do you think it is? I think with anxiety and depression, it's usually multifactorial. And that's the case in PMOS. Anyone with a chronic health condition typically has a higher risk of anxiety and depression. We also know that women with PMOS have more issues with body image and higher rates of eating disorders. And a lot of that is,
也就是你提到的女性和多囊卵巢综合征（PCOS）患者中，焦虑、抑郁以及无数其他心理健康问题的增加几率、可能性或普遍性，我想知道为什么会这样？纯粹是因为他们正在经历一个被忽视的医疗问题吗？所以这是情境性的吗？是环境因素吗？还是生物学或社会因素？你认为为什么会这样？我认为对于焦虑和抑郁来说，通常是多因素导致的。多囊卵巢综合征（PCOS）也是如此。任何患有慢性健康状况的人通常都面临更高的焦虑和抑郁风险。我们还知道，患有多囊卵巢综合征的女性有更多的问题与身体形象有关，并且饮食失调的发病率更高。其中很大一部分，
from what we know, is it at least in part related to the fact that there is a nutritional component. And if you're told that the only way that you're going to get better is if you lose weight, If you cut carbs and all of the pressures put on you, that can create very troubled relationships with food. So I think it's a component of this likely the kind of hormonal systems are probably at play here and impacting women. We know that the hormones of your menstrual cycle that are impacted here are not just sex hormones. They impact everything. You know, you've got estrogen receptors on your brain. So it's likely hormones are play. But the kind of experience of being a woman with PMOS is just hugely stressful in itself and living with that. And it's not
据我们所知，至少部分与存在营养成分有关。如果有人告诉你，你变好的唯一方法就是减肥、戒掉碳水化合物，以及施加在你身上的所有压力，这可能会导致与食物产生非常糟糕的关系。所以我认为这是其中的一部分，可能荷尔蒙系统也在其中发挥作用并对女性产生影响。我们知道，受影响的月经周期荷尔蒙不仅仅是性荷尔蒙。它们影响一切。你知道，你的大脑上有雌激素受体。所以荷尔蒙很可能在起作用。但作为一个患有多囊卵巢综合征的女性，这种经历本身就极其充满压力，并且要带着这种病生活。而且这不
just, you know, it's not something that's curable from what we know. You may get to a point where you are living mostly asymptomatic and that would be amazing. But for a lot of women, they really struggle to get there. And there's just such little support. And from what we spoke about earlier, you know, physical manifestations can be really hard for women, fertility problems. There's, I guess there's what I'm trying to say, there's so many things that could be contributing. Yeah. And I like that you have said that rather than just being, that's just a hormonal thing.
仅仅是，你知道，就我们所知，这不是一种可以治愈的病。你可能会达到这样一个阶段，即你的生活基本没有症状，那将是太棒了。但对许多女性来说，她们很难走到那一步。而且支持实在太少了。从我们刚才谈到的来看，你知道，生理上的表现对女性来说真的很艰难，生育问题。我想我要说的是，有太多因素在起作用。是的。我很高兴你这么说，而不是简单地认为这只是一种荷尔蒙问题。
Yeah. Because I do think a large part of it as well is dismissal. And the fact that you are staring down at like the barrel of a diagnosis that, as you said, doesn't have a cure. But then also you can't find a way to manage it. And then there's probably somebody being like, I don't know if you have that or not. And you're like, wait, but I, what? am I meant to do? Do I feel it so deeply that this is impacting me, but maybe I don't have it.
是的。因为我也认为其中很大一部分原因是遭到否定。以及你正面对着这样一个诊断结果的枪口，正如你所说，这无法治愈。但同时你也找不到方法来控制它。然后可能有人会说：“我不知道你到底有没有这个病。”而你会想：“等等，但是我……什么？我该怎么办？我深切地感受到这对我有影响，但也许我并没有这个病？”
A doctor took a while to diagnose me. Now they're saying, come back when you get pregnant. What is the impact of that on our psyche? Like in your patients or the people that you see, you know, how much of the mental distress is nobody believes me or nobody can help me. Yeah. I think, I mean, it's massive and it goes for so many women's health conditions beyond PMOS, you know, endometriosis takes eight years to be diagnosed. Wait, eight years? Yeah, eight years on average, like globally. Oh, I didn't even know.
医生花了一段时间才诊断出我。现在他们说：“等你怀孕了再回来。”这对我们的心理有什么影响？比如在你的患者或你看到的人当中，（你知道）有多少心理痛苦来自于“没人相信我”或“没人能帮我”？是的。我的意思是，这非常巨大，而且不仅限于多囊卵巢综合征（PCOS），它适用于许多女性健康状况，你知道，子宫内膜异位症需要八年时间才能被确诊。等等，八年？是的，平均八年，全球范围内都是如此。哦，我甚至都不知道。
That is insane. It's insane. And the UK, there was a report in the UK not too long ago, which there was this fact from it, which was so shocking that on average women had gone to their doctor more than 10 times, their GP more than 10 times before a referral for investigations, which is, you is just wild. So I think PMOS slightly shorter time to diagnosis largely because different ways that we diagnose it's less invasive. But I think having PMS myself, I'm probably more empathetic to it than someone else. And it's just having consultations with women who have
这太疯狂了。太疯狂了。在英国，不久前有一份关于英国的报告，其中有一个事实非常令人震惊，那就是女性在被转诊进行检查之前，平均已经去看过她们的医生（全科医生）超过10次，这简直是太离谱了。所以我认为多囊卵巢综合征的确诊时间稍微短一些，主要是因为我们诊断的不同方式侵入性更小。但我想我自己也患有PCOS，我对它的共情可能比别人更多。与那些经历过的女性进行咨询时，
maybe been waiting for a really long time or they have the diagnosis but they've been sent away because there's not really anything that they've been offered. Just being able to speak to someone who understands the condition, they will be hugely emotional. And I think they find that hugely therapeutic because no one explained to them what it is or what that means for their fertility or their future health or what they can do outside of pills or having babies.
也许已经等了很久，或者她们得到了诊断，但由于没有什么可以提供给她们而被打发走了。仅仅能够与一个了解这种病情的人交谈，她们就会情绪激动。我认为她们会觉得这非常具有治疗效果，因为没有人向她们解释过这是什么，或者这对她们的生育能力或未来健康意味着什么，或者除了吃药或生孩子之外她们还能做什么。
And I think, you know, even from a public health, perspective. There's not much knowledge out there. There's not more kind of, there's maybe one charity in the UK that supports PMOS, but there's not much being done in the way of like public health messaging, supporting women who have that beyond go see a private doctor. And, you know, from your experience or from other people's experience, that's not even always a great experience. No, it wasn't. It wasn't a great experience. But I think that I like that you've pointed to this something you said, this amazing point, which is the benefit of like catharsis of somebody coming to you and being like, oh my God, thank you for listening to me.
我认为，即使从公共卫生的角度来看，也没有太多相关的知识。没有更多的，英国可能有一个支持多囊卵巢综合征的慈善机构，但在公共卫生信息传递方面做得还不够，除了去看私人医生之外，没有给患有这种疾病的女性提供多少支持。而且，从你的经验或别人的经验来看，这甚至并不总是一个很好的经历。不，不是的。这不是一次很好的经历。但我很高兴你指出了这一点，你说了这样一个了不起的观点，那就是宣泄的好处，有人来找你并说：“哦，天哪，谢谢你听我说话。”
Thank you for just like letting me say that. And I'm sure like the stress levels plummet immediately, probably. And like just this tension that you're like you're holding is finally released. And what's interesting to me is the role of stress in PMOS, which I want to ask you about. and how significant it is. And the process of getting diagnosed, the process of getting help, the process of maybe pursuing, like, your fertility journey is so stressful. It's kind of like, wait, don't be stressed, but like this condition is so uniquely stressful that it's like almost impossible. Maybe I should have asked you this earlier, but can you talk about the role of, yeah, stress and all of those things on the systems of somebody with PMS?
“谢谢你让我把话说出来。”我相信压力水平可能立刻就会骤降。就像你一直紧绷的那种紧张感终于得到了释放。对我来说有趣的是压力在多囊卵巢综合征中的作用，我想问你关于这个的问题。它有多重要？诊断的过程、寻求帮助的过程、可能追求生育旅的过程是如此充满压力。这有点像，等等，不要有压力，但这种疾病又是如此独特地充满压力，以至于几乎是不可能的。也许我应该早点问你这个问题，你能谈谈压力以及所有这些因素对多囊卵巢综合征患者身体系统的影响吗？
Yes. Stress is hugely impacted. it. Stress is hugely impactful on our hormones in general and our sex hormones. And that goes for all women. So there are multiple different types of stress hormones, but the main one is cortisol that we often talk about. And that can impact our ovarian access. So the hormones that are released from our brain that tell our ovaries to produce hormones. Cortisol can basically downregulate that. So it can switch off those signals when you're going through chronic stress. And a really good example of this is when we were going through the pandemic, so many women found that their cycles
是的。压力对其有巨大的影响。压力对我们的整体荷尔蒙以及性荷尔蒙有巨大的影响。这对所有女性都适用。所以有多种不同类型的压力荷尔蒙，但我们经常谈论的主要的一种是皮质醇。这会影响我们的卵巢轴。也就是我们大脑释放的告诉我们的卵巢产生荷尔蒙的荷尔蒙。皮质醇基本上可以下调这种作用。所以当你经历慢性压力时，它可以关闭这些信号。一个很好的例子是当我们经历大流行时，许多女性发现她们的周期
had skipped a month or their cycles were really long, like globally, because we were all going through this insanely stressful event. Now, that can happen in PMOS, and it can also happen when women are going through kind of physical stress, be that they're extreme dieting, doing a lot of exercise, going through anything that's physically demanding. Your body basically is switching off signals because right now it's not a safe time to have a baby. In PMOS, that can happen, but also cortisol may increase the production of things like androgens, testosterone. And there's an association with PMOS where women may have higher levels of cortisol who have PMS. So baseline levels are slightly higher. And then if you're kind of more stressed,
一个月没来，或者她们的周期变得很长，在全球范围内都是如此，因为我们都在经历这个疯狂的充满压力的事件。现在，这种情况可能会发生在多囊卵巢综合征中，当女性经历某种身体压力时也会发生，不管是极端的节食、大量的运动，还是经历任何对身体有要求的活动。你的身体基本上在关闭信号，因为现在生孩子并不是一个安全的时机。在多囊卵巢综合征中，这种情况可能会发生，但皮质醇也可能增加雄激素、睾酮等物质的产生。多囊卵巢综合征与此有一种关联，即患有PCOS的女性可能皮质醇水平更高。所以基线水平略高。然后如果你更有压力，
you're kind of increasing that even further. So it's not great. So stress management is a huge part of the picture when it comes to helping improve PMOS symptoms. Now, I think when it comes to stress management, often the advice is just stress less. Like, don't be a stress. And goodbye. Have you tried meditation? Yeah. And I think also for a lot of people, it naturally falls to the bottom of the pile of the things that we're going to prioritize. like, you know, supplements is far more tangible. I can take a pill, I can get on what my day. How do I manage my stress when I'm working like 10 hour days? I'm, you know, moving house, moving country, whatever it might be. So I think how I speak to my clients about it is integrating kind of stress management buckets in your day,
你就会进一步增加这种水平。所以这并不好。因此，在帮助改善多囊卵巢综合征症状方面，压力管理是其中的重要组成部分。现在，我认为在谈到压力管理时，通常的建议就是少压力。就像，别给自己压力。然后就再见。你试过冥想吗？是的。我也认为对许多人来说，它自然而然地落在了我们要优先处理的事情清单的最底部，你知道，补充剂要切实得多。我可以吃一颗药，然后继续过我的日子。当我每天工作10个小时的时候，我该如何管理我的压力？我，你知道，搬家，换国家，不管是什么。所以我与客户交流的方式是将各种压力管理的“小桶”融入到你的一天中，
where you can like dial down the amount of stress you experience. And that might be that for the first 30 minutes of your day, you're not going straight in your phone because cortisol is highest in the morning. If you get up and you're looking at your phone, looking at your emails, you're just increasing that further. If you're getting up doing fasted exercise, that's also quite a big stress with PMOS. With women in general, I'm not a huge fan of fasted exercise because we're increasing cortisol when we don't need to do that. So it's those little things. It doesn't need to be like huge hours of journaling or hours of meditation. It could be downloading a meditation app and doing five minutes, 10 minutes a day.
在那里你可以调低你所经历的压力。可能的情况是，在一天的前30分钟里，你不要直接去看手机，因为皮质醇在早晨是最高的。如果你起床后看手机、看电子邮件，你只会进一步增加皮质醇。如果你起床后做空腹运动，这对多囊卵巢综合征来说也是一个相当大的压力。对广大女性而言，我不是很喜欢空腹运动，因为我们在不需要这样做的时候增加了皮质醇。所以就是这些小事。它不需要像长时间写日记或长时间冥想那样。它可以是下载一个冥想应用程序，一天做五分钟、十分钟。
but stress management for every single woman with PMOS is very important. And I found this when I, when I moved countries at the start of the year, was like when my symptoms were the worst. And I remember saying to my mom actually, I was like, I don't understand. Like I'm actually doing everything right. You know, I'm according to like this information I was given, you know, I'm like doing so good with like not eating processed carbs. and I'm eating my three meals a day and I'm hitting my protein goal.
但压力管理对于每一个患有多囊卵巢综合征的女性来说都非常重要。我在今年年初搬家时发现了这一点，当时我的症状最严重。我实际上记得对我的妈妈说，我说：“我不明白。我实际上把所有事情都做对了。”你知道，根据给我的这些信息，你知道，我做得很好，比如不吃加工碳水化合物，
And I think that is the invisible factor of like stress feels like a necessity for so many things that it's sometimes like the last thing we want to cut out. Yes. Do you know what I mean? It's almost like it's like the alcohol or like the cigarette of like the emotional states. Yeah. Where it's like, but I need my stress. I need my stress to like get stuff done and I need my stress to like be successful. And then it's, you eventually get to a point where you're like, but also I, I, I.
我一日三餐都在吃，而且达到了我的蛋白质目标。我认为这是压力的一个无形因素，因为对于许多事情来说，压力感觉就像是一种必需品，以至于有时它成为我们最不想剔除的东西。是的。你知道我的意思吗？它几乎就像是情绪状态中的酒精或香烟。是的。就好像，我需要我的压力。我需要我的压力来完成事情，我需要我的压力来取得成功。然后，你最终会达到一个阶段，你会想：“但同时，我，我，我……”
I need to be healthy. And we don't really consider it until you exit a period of that. Like you accidentally have a period where you're not as stressed and you're like, wow, my body functions so much better. So much better. I'm going to ask you some questions now about what actually works with PMOS. Actually, before I do that, I don't want to skip over this, which is getting diagnosed. And if you've been had, what does that actually look like?
我需要保持健康。在我们摆脱这段时期之前，我们并没有真正考虑到这一点。就像你不经意间经历了一段不那么有压力的时期，然后你会想：“哇，我的身体运转得好多了。好太多了。”我现在要问你一些关于多囊卵巢综合征真正起作用的是什么的问题。事实上，在此之前，我不想跳过这一点，那就是获得诊断。如果你已经被确诊了，那实际上是什么样的？
you go to a GP's office, if you go to a doctor's office, what should you are, I don't know if you're allowed to do this in the UK, but what should you ask for? What should you mention that you, you know, that will get people paying attention? How do you advocate for yourself just very quickly before we go into? Yeah, great question. I think first of all, your cycle length is an important factor. Now, if you have regular cycles, that doesn't mean that you don't have PMOS, but it can be a really big feature. So first of all, if you're not tracking your cycle, I would really do that. So you can have at least three cycles worth of like, this is what's happening. I would also list the symptoms that you're experiencing because first of all, you have them
你去了全科医生的办公室，如果你去了医生的办公室，你应该要求什么？我不知道你在英国是否被允许这样做，但你应该要求什么？你应该提及什么，你知道，这能引起人们的注意？在你我们深入探讨之前，如何非常迅速地为自己发声？是的，这是一个很好的问题。首先，我认为你的周期长度是一个重要因素。现在，如果你的周期很规律，这并不意味着你没有多囊卵巢综合征，但它可能是一个非常重要的特征。所以首先，如果你没有记录你的周期，我真的建议你这样做。这样你就可以至少有三个周期的记录，说明发生了什么。我还会列出你正在经历的症状，首先是因为你有这些症状
to hand. It's easy to forget things when you're in a 10 minute appointment and you're feeling pressure with like a doctor staring down at you and asking you to kind of hurry up. And it just helps you to kind of know what are the patterns with my symptoms as well. the main things as we mentioned earlier for getting the diagnosis are those that criteria so two of three and that's the same even though we've changed the name the criteria for diagnosis is the same so irregular cycles evidence of raised testosterone or polycystic ovaries on a scan so to get diagnosed we want to know your symptoms so that's what you're going to bring we'll do a blood test to see if you've got
随时备查。当你只有10分钟的预约时间，面对一个盯着你看、催促你快点的医生感到压力时，很容易忘记事情。这也帮助你了解我的症状有什么规律。正如我们之前提到的，确诊的主要因素是符合这些标准，即三项中满足两项。而且，尽管我们改了名字，但诊断标准是一样的：月经不规律、血液中睾酮升高的证据，或者扫描显示多囊卵巢。所以为了确诊，我们需要知道你的症状，这就是你要带来的东西。我们将做一个血液检查，看看你是否有
raised testosterone and sometimes you don't have to go further than that you could be diagnosed with just that because you're meeting two of three criteria in some cases if you don't then you'll be referred for an ultrasound scan and that is a transvaginal scan so they kind of basically put the probe inside your vagina and look at your ovaries um beyond that we should also be just doing our due diligence checking things like your blood sugar balance or what we do we use a different test in the UK, called HBA1C, and checking risk factors, so making sure your blood pressure is okay and cholesterol levels and asking you a little bit about your family history. That's the main things for PMOS. Okay. That's good to know because I didn't do a testosterone test until like this
睾酮升高。有时你不需要做更多检查，仅凭这些就可以确诊，因为你符合三项标准中的两项。在某些情况下，如果你不符合，你将被转诊去做超声扫描，那是一种经阴道扫描，所以他们基本上把探头放入你的阴道内来观察你的卵巢。除此之外，我们还应该做好尽职调查，检查诸如你的血糖平衡之类的东西，或者我们在英国使用的一种不同的测试，叫做糖化血红蛋白（HBA1C），并检查风险因素，确保你的血压正常、胆固醇水平正常，并询问你一些关于家族史的情况。这就是多囊卵巢综合征的主要检查内容。好的。很高兴知道这一点，因为直到今年最近我才做了睾酮测试，这太有趣了，如果能避免你给出的第三个选项就好了。是的。龙莓与热带莓活力饮品，麦当劳现已推出。
year recently, which is like so interesting that that would have been nice to avoid the third option that you gave. Yes. Dragonberry and Tropicberry Energizers, now at McDonald's. Made with freeze-dried fruit and an electric burst of flavor. The all-new Red Bull Energizers, now at McDonald's.
由冻干水果制成，带来激爽的风味爆发。全新红牛活力饮品，麦当劳现已推出。
This product may not be right for you. High in caffeine, details on McDonald's.ca. At participating Canadian restaurants, excluding Quebec. Hey, this is Hayes Davenport. And Sean Clements. We host the podcast, Hollywood Handbook. Every episode we're trying to help our guests improve their careers by mainly focusing on how they can help
本产品可能不适合您。咖啡因含量高，详情请参见McDonalds.ca。参与活动的加拿大餐厅（魁北克省除外）有售。嗨，我是海斯·达文波特（Hayes Davenport）。我是肖恩·克莱门茨（Sean Clements）。我们是播客《好莱坞手册》（Hollywood Handbook）的主持人。每一集我们都在尝试帮助我们的嘉宾改善他们的职业生涯，主要是通过关注他们如何帮助
us improve our careers. The show is famously super accessible so you can easily jump into any of our 650 episodes and understand what's going on. We recommend some of our recent episodes with Ben Stillard. The definition of what is a movie has kind of changed anywhere too, right? What do you think it is now? It's images and words being spoken, captured by some sort of technology. Danny McBride. Oh, that's fantastic.
我们改善我们的职业生涯。这个节目以超级平易近人而闻名，所以你可以轻松地跳进我们650集中的任何一集并听懂我们在聊什么。我们推荐一些我们最近邀请本·斯蒂勒（Ben Stillard）的节目。电影的定义其实在任何地方也都变了，对吧？你觉得现在它是什么？是由某种技术捕获的图像和说出的文字。丹尼·麦克布莱德（Danny McBride）。哦，那太棒了。
And you make it on, you make your own. That's great. I call him Tarot Reed. It's a good name. They're all named after cast members of American Pie. Yeah. Oh, gotcha. I call, I don't, I never looked up if she was in this, but I call him Leachie Sobieski.
而且你是自己拍的，你拍你自己的。那太好了。我叫他塔罗·里德（Tarot Reed）。这是个好名字。他们都是以《美国派》（American Pie）的演员名字命名的。是的。哦，明白了。我叫，我没有，我从没查过她是不是在这部剧里，但我叫她利奇·索别斯基（Leech Sobieski）。
Yeah. I don't think she was an American Pie, but I still like that. Haven't looked it up. She was prominent around the same time. Yeah. Then Mary Steenbergin. Why are you guys talking to me? I'm worried.
是的。我不认为她演过《美国派》，但我还是喜欢这个名字。我没查过。她在同一时期很出名。是的。然后是玛丽·斯汀伯根（Mary Steenbergin）。你们为什么跟我说话？我很担心。
I'm worried. Why are you talking so down to me that you think I don't understand your little play, play game? I just really. I get it. I'm trying to set you up for success here. Listen to Hollywood. handbook on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Nick Totoro.
我很担心。你们为什么这么居高之地跟我说话，觉得我听不懂你们那些小把戏游戏？我只是真的。我懂的。我是在为你创造成功铺路。收听iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方的《好莱坞手册》。我是尼克·托托罗（Nick Totoro）。
You probably know me from NYPD Blue, the longest yard, or Spike Lee's Black Klansman. But I'm also from Queens, which means I know pizza. And on my new podcast, delivering happiness with Nick Totoro, I deliver pizza from Prince Street pizza to a new guest. Are you delivering pizza now? Then we sit down for a real conversation. I've shared a slice with everyone from Seth Rollins. What are you doing, my belt?
你可能从《纽约重案组》（NYPD Blue）、《最长的一码》（The Longest Yard）或斯派克·李（Spike Lee）的《黑色党徒》（Black Klansman）中认识我。但我也来自皇后区，这意味着我懂披萨。在我的新播客《与尼克·托托罗一起传递快乐》（Delivering Happiness with Nick Totoro）中，我把来自王子街披萨（Prince Street Pizza）的披萨送到一位新嘉宾手中。你现在是在送披萨吗？然后我们坐下来进行真正的对话。我已经和每个人分享过一块披萨，从赛斯·罗林斯（Seth Rollins）。你在干什么，我的腰带？
To Alex Rodriguez. Just to let you people know. We're talking to one of the goats here. To Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am. And now we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Tuturo.
到亚历克斯·罗德里格斯（Alex Rodriguez）。让你们这些人知道。我们正在和其中一位传奇人物交谈。到比尔·伯尔（Bill Burr）。我想我从未遇到过像我这样如此精神失常的人。现在我们还有更多优秀的嘉宾要来，包括伟大的约翰·特托罗（John Tuturo）。
It's called Happiness. Delivering Happiness. Mariano Rivera. Oh, my God. And many, many more. Open your free High Heart Radio app. Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Totoro. And listen now.
它叫快乐。传递快乐。马里亚诺·里维拉（Mariano Rivera）。哦，天哪。还有很多很多。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索“Delivering Happiness with Nick Totoro”。现在就收听。
I'm Hoda Kotbi, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. If you know me, you know, I'm always searching for inspiration and useful tools to maximize joy. So this podcast lets us uncover those things together through meaningful conversations with fascinating people. Like when my friend Henry Winkler offered advice to aspiring actors and really anybody hoping to stand out. You're not hired just to fill time and space. You're hired to fill the space with you. You have something in your guts. You go with it.
我是霍达·科特比（Hoda Kotbi），播客《与霍达·科特比一起寻找快乐101》（Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby）的主持人。如果你了解我，你就会知道，我一直在寻找灵感和实用的工具来最大化快乐。所以这个播客让我们通过与迷人人物的有意义的对话，一起发现这些东西。就像我的朋友亨利·温克勒（Henry Winkler）为有志向的演员以及任何希望脱颖而出的人提供建议时所说的那样。你被雇佣不仅仅是为了填补时间和空间。你被雇佣是为了用你自己填满这个空间。你的内心深处有某种东西。你顺其自然。
And Sean Johnson recalled the moment she realized her now husband, Andrew, was the one. He was just so unapologetically himself and knew nothing of Hollywood. He hadn't been on a plane before without his family. It was so pure. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Our town is small taters by most standards, right? But to the people who grew up here, it's every. What happens when a quiet Tennessee town becomes the front line in a battle over the future of America?
肖恩·约翰逊（Sean Johnson）回忆起她意识到现在的丈夫安德鲁（Andrew）就是那个对的人的那一刻。他只是毫无保留地做自己，对好莱坞一无所知。他在没有家人陪同的情况下以前甚至没有坐过飞机。它是如此纯粹。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《与霍达·科特比一起寻找快乐101》。按照大多数标准来看，我们的小镇都是小土豆，对吧？但是对于在这里长大的人来说，这里就是一切。当一个安静的田纳西州小镇成为关于美国未来的战斗的前线时，会发生什么？
Developers with right-wing ties have purchased hundreds of acres of land in the area. The first thing you see when it pops up is pioneers in Appalachia. But they weren't just planning houses. We need cities on a shining hill that exemplify and embody the Christian way of life. Stop right there. Is that normal? A podcast about what happens when a small town becomes the site of a site of a Christian way of a Christian way of life. a social experiment. God need men to rule.
具有右翼背景的开发商已经在该地区购买了数百英亩的土地。当它弹出来时，你看到的第一件事就是阿巴拉契亚的先驱。但他们不只是在规划房屋。我们需要一座闪耀山丘上的城市，体现并具体化基督教的生活方式。停在那里。这正常吗？这是一个关于当一个小镇成为基督教生活方式的遗址时的播客。一个社会实验。上帝需要男人来统治。
Great. And decides to fight back. Do not use my hard work to sell your bull. They're not just opposing what's being planned for here. Our hometown is not a test tube. They feel like they're standing in opposition to an entire administration. Guess you didn't move in on a bunch of dumb hillbillies now, did you? Listen to our town on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
太棒了。并决定进行反击。不要利用我的辛苦工作来兜售你们的废话。他们不仅在反对这里正在规划的事物。我们的家乡不是一个试管。他们觉得他们是在反对整个政府。我想你们现在没有搬到一群笨山民中间，对吧？在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听我们的城镇。
This is a nice segue into what's. happens next. You get the diagnosis. I would say that's a cause for celebration. Some people might feel very daunted by it, but I think it's a good thing to just know. What are some things, well, I was going to ask you what are some things that actually help? But I'm going to give you a list of some things that I've heard about. And I want you to kind of rate them out of 10 and then maybe go into some things that aren't on the list. Okay. So I spent, as I said, I spent a lot of time online on Reddit. Not just on Instagram as well.
这是一个很好的过渡，接下来会发生什么。你得到了诊断。我会说这值得庆祝。有些人可能会觉得这令人望而生畏，但我认为知道总是一件好事。有哪些事情，嗯，我本来要问你有哪些事情真的有帮助？但我要给你列出一些我听说过的事情。我想让你给它们打个分，满分10分，然后可能会谈到一些不在清单上的事情。好的。所以正如我所说，我在网上的Reddit上花了很多时间。不仅在Instagram上也是如此。
And sometimes on TikTok if I really want my sources, no, but just like looking things up online, going to forums and websites and all this stuff. I've got eight things here. Okay. That are factors in PMS might help, might not help. You ready? Yes.
有时候如果我真的想找我的来源，也会上TikTok，不是，只是在网上查阅资料，去论坛、网站和所有这些东西。我这里有八个因素。好的。这些是多囊卵巢综合征的因素，可能有用，也可能没用。准备好了吗？是的。
Okay, the pill. Oh, this is such a big one to start with. So I won't give you a quick fire answer, but I'm going to give you maybe, a six out of ten. Okay. Maybe a seven. So the answer really is it depends. Now, there's so much pill fear-mongering going on right now in general. I don't think the pill is suitable for everyone. And it also is not a cure for PMOS. So sometimes people will say, oh, the pill regulates your cycles. Not necessarily. It gives you a regular bleed because it gives you a false bleed. So
好的，避孕药。哦，这是一个很好的开端。所以我不会给你一个快问快答的答案，但我可能会给你一个……十分之六的评分。好的。也许是十分之七。所以答案实际上是：这取决于情况。现在，目前普遍存在着很多对避孕药的恐惧贩卖。我不认为避孕药适合所有人。它也不是多囊卵巢综合征的治愈方法。所以有时人们会说：“哦，避孕药可以调节你的周期。”不一定。它给你带来规律的出血，因为那是一种虚假的出血。所以
For some women with PMOS who have really irregular cycles, that's quite reassuring because every 28 days they're having a bleed. If you have very irregular cycles, and I mean like three to six a year, so not very many, it's really important that we're protecting your womb lining because if you don't bleed regularly, that builds up and it increases the risk of something called endometrial hyperplasia, which can increase the risk of endometrial cancer. So in some women with very irregular cycles, the pill is actually protective because it means that we're kind of losing that extra endometrial lining every month. So it's helpful. For some women, they take the pill with PMOS because the combined pill is anti-androgenic. So it blocks the acne symptoms, the hercetism, the hair loss, and it's really beneficial. So for those women, fantastic. if they're not issues for you or for some reason you can't take the pill because there are contraindications, then it's not an option for you. And also, I think, you know, some women experience side effects from the pill that they really don't like. And that can vary, whether that's mood, libido, whatever it is. So I'm going to give it a six out of ten, because for some women, it can be like a nine out of ten. For some women, it's a one out of ten. So it really
对于一些月经周期很不规律的多囊卵巢综合征女性来说，这相当令人安心，因为她们每28天就会有一次出血。如果你的周期很不规律，我是指一年三到六次，也就是次数非常少，保护你的子宫内膜非常重要，因为如果你不规律出血，子宫内膜就会增厚，这会增加患子宫内膜增生症的风险，进而增加患子宫内膜癌的风险。所以对于一些月经周期很不规律的女性来说，避孕药实际上具有保护作用，因为这意味着我们每个月都会脱落这层额外的子宫内膜。所以这很有帮助。对于一些女性来说，她们服用避孕药是因为复方避孕药具有抗雄激素作用。所以它可以阻止痤疮症状、多毛症、脱发，并且非常受益。所以对于这些女性来说，这太棒了。如果这些对你来说不是问题，或者由于某种原因你不能服用避孕药，因为有禁忌症，那么它对你就不是一个选择。而且，我认为，一些女性在服用避孕药时会经历她们非常不喜欢的副作用。这可能会有所不同，无论是情绪、性欲，还是其他什么。所以我给它打十分之六，因为对某些女性来说，它可以是十分之九。对某些女性来说，它是十分之一。所以这真的
depends. And this is the combined pill. What about a progesterone? How do you pronounce that? Progesterone. I always struggle with it. Is that different? Would you're waiting for that be different? Yeah. Well, the progesterone pill can be used as well. And sometimes women are given a progesterone type pill to just have a withdrawal bleed every few months. So you don't take it all month. You just take it to help you have a bleed. And some women prefer that. The thing with progesterone is that it can actually, the progesterone methods of contraception can sometimes worsen acne symptoms and that's not always spoken about so if your doctor
取决于具体情况。这是复方避孕药。那孕激素呢？这个怎么发音？孕激素（Progesterone）。我总是觉得这个词很难念。这不同吗？等待那个的体验会不同吗？是的。嗯，孕激素避孕药也可以使用。有时女性会被给予一种孕激素类的避孕药，只是为了每隔几个月有一次撤退性出血。所以你不用整月服用。你只是用它来帮助你出血。有些女性更喜欢这样。关于孕激素的事情是，它实际上，孕激素避孕方法有时会恶化痤疮症状，而这一点并不总是被公开谈论，所以如果你的医生
knows that you have PMOS and suffer with acne they shouldn't really be kind of looking at those progesterone methods I feel like that's not something that's like commonly spoken about yeah I've never heard of that that we go but again for some women they can't have the combined pills
知道你患有多囊卵巢综合征并受痤疮困扰，他们其实不应该考虑那些孕激素避孕方法。我觉得这不是一件被普遍谈论的事情。是的，我从没听说过这个，我们接着说。但同样，对于某些女性来说，她们不能吃复方避孕药，
so progester might be the only option it's it is a minefield I was just thinking that's the right word for it It's such a minefield. I do kind of really go into great detail about this in my book, but there's also a great platform. It's called The Lowdown. And it's kind of like a trip advisor for contraceptives.
所以孕激素可能是唯一的选择。这真是一个雷区。我刚才就在想，这正是形容它的好词。这绝对是一个雷区。我在我的书里对此进行了非常详细的阐述，但也有一个很好的平台。它叫“The Lowdown”（内幕）。它有点像避孕措施的猫途鹰（Tripadvisor）。
And it's run by doctors. Okay. I really rate it. So before you go into the doctor, have a read of that because you can like compare different options, see the side effects. It's really helpful. That's great. I know it's really great.
它是由医生运营的。好的。我对此评价很高。所以在你去见医生之前，先读一读那个，因为你可以比较不同的选项，查看副作用。这真的很有帮助。太棒了。我知道这真的很棒。
Oh, I'm going to leave a link to that below. Anositol. Anositol. I really rate this, so I'm going to give it an 8 out of 10. Oh my God, that's a high score. Enositol is like a type of sugar compound in the body. We can get some from food, but it really needs to be taken in supplements to get the high dose where we see benefits. And the most kind of evidence-backed form is myoanositol, or a combination of myoanositol and de-chiroinocetol.
哦，我会在下方留下一个链接。肌醇（Inositol）。肌醇。我对这个评价很高，所以我要给它打十分之八。哦天哪，这是一个很高的分数。肌醇就像是体内的某种糖类化合物。我们可以从食物中获取一些，但它确实需要通过补充剂来摄取高剂量，我们才能看到好处。证据支持度最高的形式是肌醇（myo-inositol），或者是肌醇和D-手性肌醇（D-chiro-inositol）的组合。
and this kind of works by improving your insulin sensitivity so it helps with blood sugar but it also improves ovulation and I think probably the biggest win that women experience is that if you've got irregular cycles you tend to find your cycle length starts to shorten and it you know it's it's a fantastic supplement it's well evidence backed very low side effects I don't really hear much from from people who take it But it's also not a magic bullet. And for some women, it's fantastic and they get results amazing. And they just think, oh, my God, I could never be off this. And other women try it.
这种物质通过提高你的胰岛素敏感性来发挥作用，所以它有助于血糖，但它也能改善排卵。我认为女性体验到的最大收获可能是，如果你有不规律的周期，你往往会发现你的周期长度开始缩短，而且你知道，这是一种极好的补充剂，有很好的证据支持，副作用非常低。我真的很少听到服用它的人说有什么不好的地方。但它也不是灵丹妙药。对一些女性来说，它太棒了，她们得到了惊人的效果。她们只会想：“哦，天哪，我再也不想停用这个了。”而其他女性尝试了之后，
And they're like, it actually doesn't do very much for me. And that might be because we're seeing different types of PMOS and we don't fully understand that. There we go. See, I responded really well to it because I read a couple of studies about it last year. And shout out to Grace Beverly Shreddy PMOS. You found it beneficial. Life-changing. Amazing.
却觉得：“它其实对我的作用不大。”这可能是因为我们看到了不同类型的多囊卵巢综合征，而我们还没有完全理解这一点。原来如此。看，我对它的反应非常好，因为我去年读了几篇关于它的研究。向Grace Beverly的Shreddy PCOS致敬。你发现它有益。改变人生。太棒了。
But I also have just taken my own osatol on its own. Anyways, but that's just my experience. But yeah, I like that you gave that a night. Kind of confirm something for me. I'm like, oh, it's working. Okay, great. Low carb diet. I'm going to give it like a three out of ten. So that's not because there's no evidence for low carb diets. There is. But there's nothing to say that it's better than like a moderate carb intake. So like 45% of your diet. Also, a lot of the low Carb studies are actually pretty high carb. Oh, like they're not like, not high carb, but they actually have quite a lot of carbs. They're not like ketogenic in that they're like 10% of your calories. So in these studies where women are on low carb diets, they're still eating quite a lot of carbohydrates. I generally like to keep carbohydrates in the diet because they're really great source of fiber,
但我自己也单独服用过肌醇。无论如何，这只是我的经历。不过，是的，我很高兴你给出了八分。这在某种程度上证实了我的想法。我想：“哦，它在起作用。”好的，太棒了。低碳水化合物饮食。我要给它打个十分之三左右。这并不是因为低碳水化合物饮食没有证据支持。有的。但没有什么证据表明它比适量的碳水化合物摄入（比如占你饮食的45%）更好。此外，许多低碳水化合物研究中的饮食实际上碳水化合物含量相当高。哦，就像它们不是……不是高碳水化合物，但它们的碳水化合物含量其实相当高。它们不像生酮饮食那样只占你热量的10%。所以在这些女性进行低碳水化合物饮食的研究中，她们仍然在吃相当多的碳水化合物。我通常喜欢在饮食中保留碳水化合物，因为它们是纤维、
B vitamins and other nutrients. Carbs are also important for thyroid hormone production. If they become low, that can impact your cycle. and also it's just more enjoyable like why cut out carbs if you don't need to yeah um so in my practice I always include carbohydrates in the diet and we just focus on the quality of carbohydrates
B族维生素和其他营养物质的绝佳来源。碳水化合物对于甲状腺激素的产生也很重要。如果它们变得太低，就会影响你的周期。而且这样吃也更令人愉快，如果不需要的话，为什么非要戒掉碳水化合物呢？是的。所以在我的实践中，我总是把碳水化合物纳入饮食中，我们只关注碳水化合物的质量。
so low glycemic index so carbohydrates that aren't giving you big spikes in glucose and that means you know we're choosing those that are full of fiber your whole grains your brown rice is that kind of thing um so yeah I really don't rate a low carb diet Okay. What about high protein diet? Yes, big fan of that. I think protein in the diet can be hugely satiating and also really important for kind of body composition, but also high protein diets have good evidence in PMS. Seven hours of sleep. I'm going to give a seven out of ten. I would love seven to nine. Like if you can go even more. Cosh is saying that because some women are like, I'm struggling to get seven. I have kids. I have demanding work life, all of that. So I think. on the days you can get more, go for more.
所以选择低血糖生成指数（GI）的食物，也就是不会让你的血糖大幅飙升的碳水化合物，这意味着我们要选择富含纤维的食物，比如全谷物、糙米之类的。所以，是的，我真的不看好低碳水化合物饮食。好的。高蛋白饮食呢？是的，我是它的超级粉丝。我认为饮食中的蛋白质可以极大地增加饱腹感，对身体成分也非常重要，而且高蛋白饮食在多囊卵巢综合征中也有很好的证据支持。睡满七小时。我要给它打十分之七。我希望是七到九小时。如果能睡更多的话更好。教练这么说是为了照顾那些觉得“我很难睡够七小时，我有孩子，我有要求很高的工作生活”的女性。所以我认为。在你能睡更多的日子里，尽量多睡。
But seven as a minimum. As a minimum? Sleep is so important for PMOS. What would you give nine hypothetically if I had said nine, knowing that it's not always accessible, but if it's in the perfect world. I would think nine out of ten. Okay. Red light therapy.
但七小时是底线。作为底线？睡眠对于多囊卵巢综合征太重要了。如果我假设地说九小时，你会给几分？在知道这并不总是能做到，但如果是理想世界的话。我想我会给十分之九。好的。红光疗法。
Like two out of ten because there's not really any research on red light therapy. From the top of my head, I think I've seen one study and it was an in vitro or mouse study on that and PMOS. I'm seeing more of it in the fertility space, so I don't want to eat my words. But right now I'm going to say two out of ten. Like, don't waste your time. Okay. Focus on the other things.
大概十分之二吧，因为真的没有什么关于红光疗法的研究。凭我的记忆，我好像看过一项研究，那是关于多囊卵巢综合征的体外研究或小鼠研究。我在生殖领域看到越来越多的这种疗法，所以我不想食言。但现在我要给它打十分之二。就像，不要浪费你的时间。好的。专注于其他事情吧。
It's not a big thing right now. Drinking alcohol. Zero out of ten. Okay. Well, like, do you know what? It's fine to drink. There's nothing to say that moderate consumption is going to ruin your symptoms or worsen your symptoms.
现在这不算什么大事。喝酒。十分里得零分。好吧。你知道吗？喝点酒其实没关系。没有证据表明适量饮酒会破坏你的症状或让症状恶化。
But it's not going to be helpful. alcohol is very pro-inflammatory. PMOS is a pro-inflammatory condition so we want to reduce inflammation. Drinking a lot isn't going to help. It's also going to have knock on effects on your sleep, on your stress, everything else. So it's not great. But if you have the all glass of wine here and there, I don't think it's going to cause much harm. Yeah. You don't need to get too stressed about it. No. Yeah. Lifting weights. Probably like one of my favorites. I'm going to say nine out of ten because I don't really see many drawbacks. Obviously, it requires effort.
但它没什么帮助。酒精有很强的促炎作用。PMOS是一种促炎性疾病，所以我们要减少炎症。喝太多酒对病情没有帮助。它还会对你的睡眠、压力以及其他各个方面产生连锁反应。所以它并不是个好选择。但如果你偶尔喝一杯葡萄酒，我觉得不会造成太大的伤害。对，你不需要为此感到压力太大。是的。举重。这可能是我最喜欢的项目之一。我要给它打十分里的九分，因为我真的没看到它有什么明显的缺点。当然，这需要付出努力。
Yeah. Yeah, it requires effort. So that's the only drawback. But we want to build muscle. And as PMOS, it's really important that we've got muscle mass because muscle is like a sugar sponge. So I've seen someone use this analogy of like, do you know, Wittebix, the cereal? Yeah. Yeah, I think Wiedabix is Australian.
是的。对，这需要付出努力。所以这是唯一的缺点。但我们需要锻炼肌肉。作为PMOS患者，拥有肌肉量非常重要，因为肌肉就像海绵一样可以吸收糖分。我曾看到有人用这样一个比喻，你知道Weetabix麦片吗？对，对，我觉得Weetabix是澳大利亚的。
Okay. Or is that just something that everybody claims, probably. Yeah, maybe. It sounds British, not going to lie. Yeah, we have weight fix. So if that's your muscle and then you pour milk on it and then it soaks up all that milk, that's kind of what your muscles are doing with blood sugar. Okay. So the more muscle you have, the more insulin sensitive you are. So it's really beneficial to be building muscle. And that doesn't mean that you have to like be so henshing and like have loads of muscle. But it's good to lift weights and do resistance training. So that doesn't include like small weights on your ankles when you go for a walk. I mean, like actually lifting weights. Some form of Pilates do count because I always get asked that. Like people say like does Pilates count? Some forms do. But the reformer Pilates would be like more resistance because you're actually using a lot of resistance there. Whereas if you're doing mat platas and you're not doing a huge amount, you may not be using as much stimulus. It's not to say it's redundant. I love Pilates. But I'm just saying I love when women use weights because then they're
好吧。还是这只是大家都这么说？很可能是。对，也许吧。说实话，听起来像是英国的。对，我们有Weetabix。如果那是你的肌肉，然后你把牛奶倒在上面，它就会把所有的牛奶都吸收进去，这有点像你的肌肉对血糖所做的事情。好吧。所以你的肌肉越多，对胰岛素的敏感度就越高。因此，建立肌肉真的非常有益。这并不意味着你必须练得像健美运动员那样肌肉发达。但进行举重和抗阻训练是很好的。这不包括散步时绑在脚踝上的那种小哑铃。我的意思是真正的举重。有些普拉提形式确实算数，因为总有人问我这个问题。人们会问普拉提算数吗？有些形式算。但器械普拉提会更有抗阻性，因为你在那里实际上使用了很大的阻力。而如果你在做垫上普拉提，强度不大，你可能用不到那么多的刺激。这并不是说它没用。我喜欢普拉提。但我只是想说，我喜欢女性使用哑铃，因为这样她们
adding more of a stimulus to building muscle. So there's. This is something I'm sure a lot of women have heard, which is like, you need to be lifting heavy. What does that mean? When somebody says, you need to be lifting heavy, I'm a big fan. But I remember hearing that and being like, I don't, like something over my head or like when I first started, I was like, do I push something? Or what does that mean? It is a very vague phrase. And I think it's all relative.
对建立肌肉施加了更多的刺激。所以，有一点是很多女性肯定听说过的，那就是：“你需要进行大重量举重。”这是什么意思？当有人说“你需要进行大重量举重”时，我是它的超级粉丝。但我记得当时听到这话时的反应是：我不要，是把什么东西举过头顶，还是我刚开始的时候在想，我是要推什么东西吗？或者那是什么意思？这是一个非常模糊的短语。而且我认为这都是相对的。
But moving any form of resistance, I think is beneficial. So if that's weights, if that's bans, if that's reformer, that's going to. to be muscle strengthening. So if we want to build more muscle and build strength, we need to have progressive overload. So we need to increase the amount that we're doing. So if you're, you know, if you go to the gym and for the first four weeks you're lifting, let's just say, two kilogram dumbbells, in the next couple of weeks, I want you to increase that because you need to increase the stimulus to build strength. And that's just what we mean because I think typically and this is very much like generalizing you know women use these tiny one kilogram
但进行任何形式的抗阻运动都是有益的。所以如果那是哑铃、弹力带、器械普拉提，这些都会增强肌肉。因此，如果我们想建立更多肌肉并增强力量，我们需要进行渐进式超负荷。也就是说我们需要增加训练量。所以，如果你去健身房，在前四周里，比如说，你举的是两公斤的哑铃，在接下来的几周里，我希望你增加重量，因为你需要增加刺激来增强力量。这就是我们的意思，因为我认为通常情况下——这很大程度上是一种概括——女性会用这些微小的一公斤
weights and sometimes those one kilogram weights can be really heavy if you're doing lots of reps but if you're using the big muscles of your body so that's like your quads your glutes your hamstrings your back we can lift a lot more and so we want to be kind of pushing ourselves if you're able to do 20 reps and you're not breaking a sweat you're not lifting heavy enough. I like that. I like that as a rule. Okay, I've got one more. And I just threw this one on because it was a nice fun one, which is peppermint tea. So I see your peppermint tea and I raise you spearmint tea because spearmint tea is that what's in gum? The spearmint flavor? Is that what I'm thinking? Yeah. Okay, okay, yeah. It's actually hard, it's quite hard to get your hands on like
哑铃，有时候如果你做很多次，那一公斤的哑铃其实也会变得非常重。但如果你动用身体的大块肌肉，比如股四头肌、臀大肌、腘绳肌和背部，我们就能举起更多重量。所以如果你能做20个而连汗都不出，说明你的重量还不够大。我喜欢这个。我把这当作一个规则。好吧，我还有一个。我把这个加进来是因为它是一个很有趣的选项，那就是薄荷茶。我看到你的薄荷茶，我要加码绿薄荷茶，因为绿薄荷茶——那是口香糖里的成分吗？绿薄荷味？是我在想的那种吗？对。好吧，好吧，是的。实际上很难买到那种
pure spearmint tea, but there's evidence that spearmint tea can reduce androgen, so testosterone, two cups a day. try it for three months. There is some research for it. Pepper mint tea less so, but it's good for the IBS Gerties. Oh, okay. There we go, girls. Knowing your ratings there, oh, you didn't give it, what would you give spearmint tea, sorry? I'm going to give it a five out of ten. Okay. Pepperment tea would be less. Yeah, not for PMOS. We'll give it two out of ten. Okay. If you got loading, it might be helpful. Okay, great. The hard rock bat casino app is here, Ontario. It's safe, secure, and crystal. clear with fast payouts and 24-7 local support.
纯绿薄荷茶，但有证据表明绿薄荷茶可以降低雄激素，也就是睾酮，一天两杯。尝试三个月。有一些研究支持这一点。薄荷茶的作用没那么明显，但它对肠易激综合征（IBS）和胃食管反流（GERD）有好处。哦，好吧。好了，女孩们。知道了你们的评分，哦，你还没给评分，你给绿薄荷茶打几分？抱歉？我要给它打十分里的五分。好吧。薄荷茶的评分会低一些。是的，对PMOS没太大用。我们给它打十分里的两分。好吧。如果你有这方面困扰，它可能会有帮助。好吧，太棒了。硬石在线赌场应用程序登陆安大略省了。它安全可靠，透明度高，提现快速，并提供全天候本地客服支持。
You can play over 3,000 games right here, including hard rock bet casino exclusives. The hard rock bet casino app is here, Ontario. Roll with us. Must be 19 years of age or older to play. Ontario only. Please play responsibly. Concerned about your gambling or that of someone close to you, visit connectsonterio.ca. Hey, this is Hayes Davenport.
你可以在这里玩三千多款游戏，包括硬石赌场独家游戏。硬石在线赌场应用程序登陆安大略省了。加入我们吧。必须年满19岁或以上方可游戏。仅限安大略省。请理性游戏。如果您或身边的其他人对赌博问题感到担忧，请访问connectsonterio.ca。嘿，我是海斯·达文波特。
And Sean Clements. We host the podcast Hollywood Handbook. Every episode we're trying to help our game. guests improve their careers by mainly focusing on how they can help us improve our careers. The show is famously super accessible so you can easily jump into any of our 650 episodes and understand what's going on. We recommend some of our recent episodes with Ben Stillard. The definition of what is a movie has kind of changed anywhere too, right?
我是肖恩·克莱门茨。我们是播客《好莱坞手册》的主持人。在每一集的节目中，我们都试图通过主要关注嘉宾如何帮助我们提升职业生涯，来帮助我们的嘉宾提升他们的职业生涯。这个节目以超级平易近人而闻名，所以你可以轻松地收听我们650集中的任何一集，并且听懂我们在聊什么。我们推荐一些我们最近与本·斯蒂勒合作的节目。电影的定义其实在任何地方也都变了，对吧？
What do you think it is now? It's images and words being spoken, captured by some sort of technology. Danny McBride. He loves over. Oh, that's fantastic. And you make it on, you make your own. That's great. I call him Terro Reed.
你觉得现在它是什么？它是通过某种技术捕捉到的图像和被说出的词语。丹尼·麦克布莱德。他太喜欢了。哦，这太棒了。你自己创作，你创作你自己的。那太好了。我管他叫泰瑞·里德。
It's a good name. They're all named after cast members of American Pie. Yeah. I call, I don't, I never looked up if she was in this, but I call him Leachie Sobieski. Yeah, I don't think she was an American Pie, but I still like that. Haven't looked it up. She was prominent around the same time. Yeah.
这是个好名字。他们都以《美国派》的演员命名。对。我管——我从来没查过她是不是演过这个，但我管她叫利奇·索维斯基。对，我觉得她没演过《美国派》，但我还是喜欢这个名字。没去查过。她当时也很活跃。对。
Then Mary Steenbergin. Why are you guys talking to me? I'm worried. I'm worried. Why are you talking so down to me that you think I don't understand your little play? Play game. I just really. I get it.
然后是玛丽·斯汀伯根。你们为什么跟我说话？我很担心。我很担心。你们为什么用这种居高临下的态度跟我说话，觉得我听不懂你们的小把戏？小游戏。我真的。我懂的。
I'm trying to set you up for success here. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Nick Totoro. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, the longest yard, or Spike Lee's Black Klansman. But I'm also from Queens, which means I know pizza. And on my new podcast, delivering happiness with Nick Totoro, I deliver pizza from Prince Street pizza to a new guest. Are you delivering pizza now?
我这是在帮你走向成功。在I Heart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《好莱坞手册》。我是尼克·托托罗。你可能通过《纽约重案组》、《最长的一码》或斯派克·李的《黑色党徒》认识我。但我也来自皇后区，这意味着我懂披萨。在我的新播客《与尼克·托托罗一起传递快乐》中，我把普林斯街披萨店的披萨带给一位新嘉宾。你现在开始送披萨了吗？
Then we sit down for a real conversation. I've shared a slice with everyone from Seth Rollins. What are you doing, my belt? To Alex Rodriguez. Just to let you people know, we're talking to one of the goats here. To Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am. And now, we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Tuturo.
然后我们坐下来进行一次真正的对话。我已经和从塞思·罗林斯那里的人分享过一块披萨。你在干什么，我的腰带？到亚历山大·罗德里格斯。只想让你们知道，我们正在和其中一位传奇人物对话。再到比尔·伯尔。我觉得我从来没有遇到过哪个人的精神状态像我一样这么出格。现在，我们还将迎来更多优秀的嘉宾，包括伟大的约翰·托托罗。
It's called Happiness. Delivering Happiness. Mariano Rivera. Oh, my God. And many, many more. Open your free High Heart Radio app. Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Tutro. And listen now.
它叫快乐。传递快乐。马里亚诺·里维拉。哦，天哪。还有很多很多嘉宾。打开你的免费I Heart Radio应用程序。搜索《与尼克·托托罗一起传递快乐》。现在就收听。
I'm Hoda Kotbby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotbbe. If you know me, you know, I'm always searching for inspiration and useful tools to maximize joy. So this podcast lets us uncover those things together through meaningful conversations with fascinating people. Like when my friend Henry Winkler offered advice to aspiring actors and really anybody hoping to stand out. You're not hired.
我是霍达·科特布，播客《与霍达·科特布一起寻找快乐101》的主持人。如果你了解我，你就知道我一直在寻找灵感和实用的工具来最大化快乐。所以这个播客让我们通过与迷人人物的有意义的对话，一起发掘这些东西。就像我的朋友亨利·温克勒向有志于成为演员的人以及任何希望脱颖而出的人提供建议时那样。你没有被雇用。
Just to fill time and space. You're hired to fill the space with you. You have something in your guts. You go with it. And Sean Johnson recalled the moment she realized her now husband, Andrew, was the one. He was just so unapologetically himself and knew nothing of Hollywood. He hadn't been on a plane before without his family. It was so pure.
不仅仅是为了填补时间和空间。你被雇用来用你自己填补空间。你的内心有某种直觉。你就顺着它去。肖恩·约翰逊回忆起她意识到现在的丈夫安德鲁就是对的人的那一刻。他毫无保留地做自己，对好莱坞一无所知。他在没有家人陪同的情况下甚至没坐过飞机。那是如此纯粹。
Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Our town is small taters by most standards, right? But to the people who grew up here, it's everything. What happens when a quiet Tennessee town becomes the front line in a battle over the future of America? Developers with right-wing ties have purchased hundreds of acres of land in the area. The first thing you see when it pops up is pioneers in Appalachia. But they weren't just planning houses. We need cities on a shining hill that exemplify and embody the Christian way of life.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《与霍达·科特布一起寻找快乐101》。按照大多数标准来看，我们的小镇算不上什么大地方，对吧？但对在这里长大的人来说，这一切就是全部。当一个安静的田纳西小镇成为关于美国未来之战的前线时，会发生什么？具有右翼背景的开发商已经在该地区购买了数百英亩土地。弹出的第一个画面就是阿巴拉契亚的先驱。但他们不仅在规划房屋。我们需要山巅之城来诠释和体现基督教的生活方式。
Stop right there. Is that normal? A podcast about what happens when a small town becomes the site of a social experiment. God need men to rule. Great. And decides to fight back. Do not use my hard work to sell your bull-h-h-h-hue. They're not just opposing what's being planned for here. Our hometown is not a test tube. They feel like they're standing in opposition to an entire administration.
到此为止。这正常吗？这是一个关于当一个小镇成为社会实验场时会发生什么的播客。上帝需要男人来统治。太棒了。并决定反击。不要用我的辛苦工作来兜售你们的胡说八道。他们不仅在反对这里正在规划的事物。我们的家乡不是试管。他们觉得自己在对抗整个行政当局。
Guess you didn't move in on a bunch of dumb hillbillies now, did you? Listen to our town on the I-Heart Radio. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. I walk into your office. I go, Dr. Hazel, help me. And I give you my symptoms. If you have to give like a top four, what would you say to a woman who's experiencing PMOS to start doing or to start trying or to stop doing? So I'm going to leave any medication to your to your doctor
你们大概没想到会搬到一群愚蠢的乡巴佬中间来吧？在I-Heart Radio、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《我们的小镇》。我走进你的办公室。我说，黑泽尔医生，救救我。然后我把症状告诉你。如果你必须列出前四名，你会对一个正在经历PMOS并开始行动、开始尝试或停止某些行为的女性说些什么？所以我把任何药物治疗留给你的医生。
because there are some options beyond the pill that you can discuss and also will depend on whether you are actually trying to conceive or have any risk factors what you can start
因为除了药丸之外，还有一些你可以讨论的选择，这也将取决于你是否真的在尝试怀孕或是否有任何风险因素，你可以从今天开始做什么
doing today nutrition is going to be a huge part of it first and foremost now there's no specific diet there's no single diet that will kind of cure PMOS but nutrition is so powerful
营养将是其中的重要部分，首先也是最重要的一点。现在并没有具体的饮食，没有哪一种单一饮食可以治愈PMOS，但营养的力量是如此强大
like I can't tell you enough. I feel like it transformed my symptoms and it's what I do every day in my practice. The best way to kind of like summarize what you need to do from a food perspective for PMOS is following a Mediterranean style dietary pattern. I know that we bang on about this diet for everything and that's because it does a lot of things. But because it's a dietary pattern. So it's not specific foods that you need to consume. It's not have two almonds a day or anything. It's a pattern, which is good news because it means that it's flexible to you. And what I mean by that is we want to have lots of colorful fruits and veg, whole grains, fish, nuts and seeds, moderate intake of dairy, less red meat, processed food and alcohol and sugar. Within that, when it comes to the macronutrients, the key macros are, the three are protein carbs and fats.
我简直无法向你强调。我觉得它改变了我的症状，这也是我在诊所里每天都在做的事情。从食物的角度来总结你需要为PMOS做的事情，最好的方式就是遵循地中海式的饮食模式。我知道我们对这种饮食赞不绝口，那是因为它确实有很多作用。但这是一种饮食模式。所以它不是你需要消费的具体食物。不是一天吃两个杏仁之类的。它是一种模式，这是个好消息，因为这意味着它对你来说是灵活的。我的意思是，我们要吃很多色彩缤纷的水果和蔬菜、全谷物、鱼类、坚果和种子，适量摄入乳制品，少吃红肉、加工食品、酒精和糖。在此基础上，谈到宏量营养素时，关键的三种宏量营养素是蛋白质、碳水化合物和脂肪。
We already talked about carbohydrates, but we want to have them in the diet to make up around 40% of your overall calorie intake. So present at every meal, but the high fiber, low glycemic carbohydrates. Glycemic, when we say that word, we mean blood sugar. And adding fiber to your meal reduces that glycemic impact, but also pairing carbs with fat and protein further reduces it. So if you're having a slice of toast and you add some smashed avocado and maybe a poached egg on top, you're getting carbohydrates, fats and protein. So that blood sugar response will be less than if you had a slice of sourdough with some strawberry jam on top or banana. And that's not to say that you can never have a single carb on its own because they have their place like around exercise. We want those fast acting carbs. I run a lot. I'm having bananas before I run. I'm having toast with honey on it. That is absolutely fine if you've got PMOS. But if you're sitting at your desk or you're about to go to work, we want steady energy levels and it's going to be those balanced meals that give us those steady
我们已经讨论过碳水化合物，但我们需要让它们在饮食中占到你总热量摄入的40%左右。所以每一餐都有，但要选择高纤维、低血糖生成指数的碳水化合物。血糖生成指数，当我们说这个词时，我们的意思是血糖。在你的餐食中添加纤维可以减少这种血糖影响，而且将碳水化合物与脂肪和蛋白质搭配会进一步降低这种影响。所以如果你吃一片吐司，上面加点压碎的牛油果，可能还有一个水波蛋，你就摄入了碳水化合物、脂肪和蛋白质。因此，这种血糖反应会比你吃一片带有草莓果酱或香蕉的酸面包要低。这并不是说你永远不能单独吃碳水化合物，因为它们有它们的位置，比如在运动前后。我们需要那些快速起效的碳水化合物。我经常跑步。我在跑步前会吃香蕉。我会吃涂了蜂蜜的吐司。如果你有PMOS，这绝对没问题。但如果你坐在办公桌前或正准备去上班，我们需要稳定的能量水平，而正是这些均衡的餐食为我们提供稳定的
energy. Now, I mentioned inflammation earlier and the only, the things that help reduce inflammation in the diet are all that colorful fruits and veg. And so we want as much of that in there. We want nuts and seeds. We want our oily fish. Oily fish specifically is a really great source of omega-3s. And we can get omega-3s from other sources like cheese seeds and walnuts and plant-based foods, but our body has to convert it. And that conversion is not, we're just not great at it. So if you don't have oily fish, and I'm not saying you have to, but if you don't, I would think about adding an omega-3 supplement and still prioritizing those sources.
能量。现在，我刚才提到了炎症，而饮食中唯一有助于减少炎症的东西就是所有那些色彩缤纷的水果和蔬菜。所以我们希望里面有尽可能多的这些东西。我们需要坚果和种子。我们需要富含脂肪的鱼类。富含脂肪的鱼类特别是不饱和脂肪酸（Omega-3）的绝佳来源。我们可以从其他来源获得Omega-3，比如奇亚籽、核桃和植物性食物，但我们的身体必须对其进行转化。这种转化并不好，我们在这方面实在不擅长。所以如果你不吃富含脂肪的鱼类——我并不是说你必须吃——但如果你不吃，我会考虑添加Omega-3补充剂，同时仍然优先考虑那些食物来源。
because omega 3 is hugely beneficial in PMOS. We've got lots of good evidence behind that. That's really diet in a nutshell. We kind of said, we mentioned alcohol. Ideally, limit it as much as you can, limit as much processed food as you can. But if you're traveling for work and you're in an airport and the only thing that you can get is a processed snack, one day of kind of processed foods is not going to derail you. It's what you do 80% of the time that will impact you the most.
因为Omega-3对PMOS非常有利。我们有很多充分的证据支持这一点。简而言之，这就是饮食。我们刚才提到了酒精。理想情况下，尽可能多地限制它，尽可能多地限制加工食品。但如果你因工作出差在机场，你唯一能买到的就是一份加工零食，吃一天的加工食品并不会毁了你。真正对你影响最大的是你80%的时间在做什么。
not what you do 20% at the time. So that's nutrition. And then supplementation, annoying answer, but it does depend. I think Nocetal is a great one for most women at PMOS. Give it a go for three months anyway. In the UK, vitamin D is a big one because we don't get much sunlight.
而不是你20%的时间在做什么。这就是营养。接下来是补充剂，这是一个令人头疼的答案，但它确实取决于个人。我认为肌醇（Inositol）对大多数患有PMOS的女性来说是一个很好的选择。无论如何，试用三个月。在英国，维生素D是一个大问题，因为我们照不到多少阳光。
Low levels of vitamin D are quite common in PMS. And if you've got low levels, that may worsen symptoms. So I tend to look at supplementation, but always look at people's blood tests first. And then on top of that, it's really variable. So like I mentioned, omega-3. If you're getting two portions of oily fish in your diet,
维生素D水平低在PMS中很常见。如果你的水平较低，可能会使症状恶化。所以我倾向于考虑补充剂，但总是先查看人们的血液检测结果。在此基础之上，情况变量非常大。就像我提到的Omega-3。如果你的饮食中能吃到两份富含脂肪的鱼类，
there's no point me adding omega-3 into your diet supplementation. There are other supplements that people try, and that could be magnesium, berberine, chromium, copper, loads of different ones. They have varying amounts of evidence. You'd probably be surprised at how little, I prescribe supplements because I think if you can get it from your diet, I really don't want to be giving you loads of supplements. The supplement industry is so poorly regulated as well. And I think
我在你的饮食中添加Omega-3补充剂就没有任何意义了。人们还会尝试其他补充剂，可能是镁、小檗碱（黄连素）、铬、铜，种类繁多。它们有不同程度的证据支持。你可能会惊讶于我开补充剂的频率有多低，因为我认为如果你能从饮食中获取，我真的不想给你服用大量的补充剂。而且补充剂行业的监管非常松散。我认为
nothing's better than a food-first approach. Yeah. And outside of food, exercise, sleep and stress management are the other things. So exercise, there's no single best form of exercise when it comes to PMS. A lot of people say only do low intensity, that's not true. That was going to be one of my questions. I always see people being like, don't do hit workouts. Yes. But I love, I have this one class I talk about on this podcast all the time called sculpt that is just like a hit workout in like a sauna basically. And I've always like, should I be doing that? What's your take on, yeah, on hit workouts? So I've really wanted to talk about this because I find it really surprised. that this is a big thing, like it's a big myth, because the research shows the opposite.
没有什么比“食物优先”的方法更好的了。是的。除了食物之外，运动、睡眠和压力管理是其他几个方面。所以说到运动，并没有哪一种单一的最佳运动形式适合经前期综合征（PMS）。很多人说只能做低强度运动，那不是真的。这正好是我的问题之一。我经常看到有人说，不要做高强度间歇训练（HIIT）。是的。但我很喜欢，我在这个播客里经常提到一个叫 sculpt 的课程，它基本上就像是在桑拿房里上 HIIT 课。我一直都在想，我应该去上这门课吗？你对 HIIT 训练有什么看法？所以我真的很想谈谈这个，因为我发现这竟然是个大问题，是个巨大的误区，而研究结果恰恰相反。
There's like good research to say high intensity exercise improves PMOS symptoms. And when we pool together all the different exercise studies in PMS, there's no superior type that's like best for women with PMS. It's kind of a combination of both. The caveat to that is, and this is where I think because some people I speak to say, well, actually, I know high-intensity exercise or running made my symptoms worse. And then when we kind of get into the grains of salt or whatever the phrases for it. The grains of rise? Grains of rise.
有很好的研究表明，高强度运动可以改善经前期综合征（PMS）的症状。当我们把所有关于 PMS 的不同运动研究汇集在一起时，并没有哪一种类型的运动对患有 PMS 的女性来说是绝对最好的。它其实是两者的结合。需要说明的一点是——这也是为什么我跟一些人交流时，他们会说：“其实我知道高强度运动或跑步让我的症状更严重了”——然后当我们开始探讨其中的细节时，或者不管用什么词来形容……是“微小细节”吗？微小细节。
So we get into the rise. We're getting to the rise. What I realize is it's actually, it's not the high-intensity exercise. That's the problem. It's the fact that you're doing loads of exercise fasted. And you're doing a ton of exercise and you're not making time for recovery and your sleep is off. So we're under fueling and we're under recovering and we're doing too much exercise. And actually, if we bring down the intensity of how much you're doing, so instead of doing seven back-to-back Barry's classes every week, we're doing three hit workouts and two strength sessions per week.
所以我们开始探讨细节。我们正在进入细节。我意识到其实问题不在于高强度运动本身。问题在于你空腹做了大量的运动。你做了大量的运动，却没有留出时间恢复，而且你的睡眠也不规律。所以我们摄入的能量不足，恢复不足，运动过量。实际上，如果我们降低运动强度和运动量——比如，我们不再每周连续去上七节 Barry's 训练课，而是改为每周进行三次 HIIT 训练和两次力量训练——
We're fueling before we go to the gym or for our hit sessions. We're making sure we're optimizing our recovery afterwards. we're resting. No longer do we see those issues. And that goes for every woman with or without PMS. It is not bad for you. It doesn't harm your hormones. But if it's all you do, you're not recovering and you're underfeeling,
我们在去健身房前或进行 HIIT 训练前补充能量。我们确保在训练后优化恢复。我们好好休息。我们就不会再看到那些问题了。这适用于所有患有或不患有 PMS 的女性。它对你没有坏处。它不会损害你的荷尔蒙。但如果这就是你全部的运动方式，你没有恢复，而且营养摄入不足，
you're going to have issues. I like the caveat. The new Red Bull, Dragonberry and Tropicberry Energizers, now at McDonald's, made with freeze-dried fruit and an electric burst of flavor. The all-new Red Bull Energizers. Now at McDonald's. This product may not be right for you.
你就会出现问题。我喜欢这个说明。麦当劳全新推出的红牛龙莓和热带莓能量饮品，现已在麦当劳上市，采用冻干水果制作，带来爆发力十足的口感。全新红牛能量饮品。现已在麦当劳上市。本产品可能不适合你。
High in caffeine, details at McDonald's.ca. At participating Canadian restaurants, excluding Quebec. Hey, this is Hayes Davenport. And Sean Clements. We host the podcast, Hollywood Handbook. Every episode we're trying to help our guests improve their careers by mainly focusing on how they can help us improve our careers. The show's famously super accessible so you can easily jump into any of our 650 episodes
咖啡因含量高，详情请访问 McDonald's.ca。仅限参与活动的加拿大餐厅，魁北克省除外。嘿，我是海斯·达文波特（Hayes Davenport）。我是肖恩·克莱门茨（Sean Clements）。我们是播客《好莱坞手册》（Hollywood Handbook）的主持人。在每一集里，我们都试图通过主要关注嘉宾如何帮助我们提升职业生涯，来帮助他们提升职业生涯。这个节目以超级容易上手而闻名，所以你可以轻松收听我们总共 650 集中的任何一集，
and understand what's going on. We recommend some of our recent episodes with Ben Stiller. The definition of what is a movie has kind of changed anywhere, too, right? What do you think it is now? It's images and words being spoken, captured by some sort of technology. Danny McBride. He loves Calvin. Oh, that's fantastic.
并听懂我们在聊什么。我们推荐一些我们最近邀请本·斯蒂勒（Ben Stiller）的节目。电影的定义其实在任何地方也都变了，对吧？你觉得现在它是什么？它是通过某种技术捕捉到的图像和说出的文字。丹尼·麦克布莱德（Danny McBride）。他喜欢卡尔文（Calvin）。哦，那太棒了。
And you make it on, you make your own. That's great. I call him Terro Reed. It's a good name. They're all named after cast members of American Pie. Yeah. I call, I don't, I never looked up if she was a. in this, but I call him Leachie Sobieski.
而且你自己制作。那太好了。我管他叫塔罗·里德（Terro Reed）。这是个好名字。他们都是以《美国派》的演员命名的。是的。我叫……其实我从没查过她是不是里面的人，但我管她叫莉奇·索别斯基（Leachie Sobieski）。
I don't think she was an American pie, but I still like that. I haven't looked it up. She was prominent around the same time. Then Mary Steenbergin. Why are you guys talking to me? I'm worried. Why are you talking so down to me that you think I don't understand your little
我不觉得她演过《美国派》，但我还是挺喜欢这个名字的。我没去查过。她和那个时期的人很红。然后是玛丽·斯汀伯根（Mary Steenburgen）。你们为什么跟我说这些？我很担心。你们为什么用这种居高临下的态度跟我说话，觉得我听不懂你们的小
play game? I just really I'm trying to set you up for success here. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Nick Tuttle. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, the longest yard, or Spike Lee's Black Klansman. But I'm also from Queens, which means I know pizza. And on my new podcast, delivering happiness with Nick Totoro, I deliver pizza from Prince
把戏？我只是……我真的只是想为你创造成功的条件。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《好莱坞手册》。我是尼克·图托罗（Nick Turturro）。你可能从《纽约重案组》（NYPD Blue）、《最长的一码》（The Longest Yard）或斯派克·李的《黑色党徒》（BlackKklansman）中认识我。但我也是来自皇后区，这意味着我懂披萨。在我的新播客《与尼克·图托罗一起传递快乐》（Delivering Happiness with Nick Turturro）中，我从王子街披萨店（Prince Street Pizza）送披萨给一位新嘉宾。
Street Pizza to a new guest. Are you delivering pizza now? Then we sit down for a real conversation. I've shared a slice with everyone from Seth Rollins. What are you doing my belt? To Alex Rodriguez. Just to let you people know, we're talking to one of the goats here. To Bill Burke.
你现在开始送披萨了吗？然后我们坐下来进行一次真正的对话。我跟各种各样的人分享过一块披萨，从赛斯·罗林斯（Seth Rollins）——你在对我的腰带做什么？——到亚历克斯·罗德里格斯（Alex Rodriguez）——为了让大家知道，我们正在和史上最伟大的人之一对话——再到比尔·伯尔（Bill Burr）。
I don't think I've ever met somebody. so exactly out of their mind as I am. And now we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Tituro. It's called Happiness. Delivering Happiness. Mariano Rivera. Oh, my God.
我想我从来没有见过哪个人的疯狂程度跟我一模一样。现在我们还将迎来更多伟大的嘉宾，包括伟大的约翰·图托罗（John Turturro）。这叫快乐。传递快乐。马里亚诺·里维拉（Mariano Rivera）。哦，天哪。
And many, many more. Open your free High Heart Radio app. Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Titoro. And listen now. I'm Hoda Kotmi, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb. If you know me, you know, I'm always searching for inspiration and useful tools to make. maximize joy. So this podcast lets us uncover those things together through meaningful conversations
还有更多很多嘉宾。打开你免费的 iHeart Radio 应用程序。搜索《与尼克·图托罗一起传递快乐》，马上收听。我是霍达·科特布（Hoda Kotb），播客《霍达的快乐101》（Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb）的主持人。如果你了解我，你就知道我一直在寻找灵感和实用的工具来最大化快乐。所以这个节目让我们通过与迷人人物的有意义对话，共同发掘这些东西，
with fascinating people. Like when my friend Henry Winkler offered advice to aspiring actors and really anybody hoping to stand out. You're not hired just to fill time and space. You're hired to fill the space with you. You have something in your guts. You go with it. And Sean Johnson and recalled the moment she realized her now husband, Andrew, was the one. He was just so unapologetically himself and knew nothing of Hollywood. He hadn't been on a plane before without his family. It was so pure. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
比如我的朋友亨利·温克勒（Henry Winkler）向有抱负的演员以及任何希望脱颖而出的人提供的建议。你被雇佣不只是为了填补时间和空间。你被雇佣是为了用你自己填满这个空间。你的内心深处有种直觉。跟着它走。肖恩·约翰逊（Sean Johnson）回忆起她意识到现在的丈夫安德鲁就是真命天子的那一刻。他就是那么毫无歉意地做自己，对好莱坞一无所知。他在没有家人陪同的情况下甚至没坐过飞机。它是如此纯粹。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《霍达的快乐101》。
Our town is small taters by most standards, right? But to the people who grew up here, it's everything. What happens when a quiet Tennessee? town becomes the front line in a battle over the future of America. Developers with right-wing ties have purchased hundreds of acres of land in the area. The first thing you see when it pops up is pioneers in Appalachia. But they weren't just planning houses. We need cities on a shining hill that exemplify and embody the Christian way of life.
按照大多数标准来看，我们的小镇只是个小地方，对吧？但对于在这里长大的人来说，这里就是一切。当一个安静的田纳西州小镇成为争夺美国未来的战场的中心时，会发生什么？有着右翼背景的开发商已经在该地区购买了数百英亩的土地。弹出的第一个画面就是“阿巴拉契亚的先驱”。但他们不仅仅是在规划房屋。我们需要建立山巅之城，以体现和实践基督的生活方式。
Stop right there. Is that normal? A podcast about what happens when a small town becomes the site of a social experiment. God need men to rule. and decides to fight back. Do not use my hard work to sell your bull-h-h-hick. They're not just opposing what's being planned for here. Our hometown is not a test tube. They feel like they're standing in opposition to an entire administration.
等一下。这正常吗？这是一个关于当一个小镇成为社会实验场地的播客。上帝需要男人来统治，并决定进行反击。不要利用我的辛苦工作来兜售你们的胡言乱语。他们不只是在反对这里正在进行的规划。我们的家乡不是试管。他们觉得他们是在反对整个行政部门。
Guess you didn't move in on a bunch of dumb hillbillies now, did you? Listen to our town on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Let's finish on an optimistic pathway. What are some of the promising things that you are seeing in the research right now that you're excited about? I think, well, I guess, first of all, the fact that PMOS has had a name change, I think, is going to open up more opportunity for researchers because it means that we're shifting our focus, which is so important because it means more research means better guidelines, more treatment options for women. but across the board we are seeing a lot of advances in diagnostics for women's health, especially when it comes to conditions like endometriosis where typically our diagnostic techniques are quite invasive where we have to look inside your tummy through surgery. And there's a lot of research looking at kind of on the spot diagnostic for endometriosis, which would be amazing. So I think that's fantastic.
我想你们现在没有搬进一群愚蠢的乡巴佬中间，对吧？在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《我们的镇》（Our Town）。让我们以乐观的方式结束。目前你在研究中看到的哪些有希望的事情让你感到兴奋？我想，首先，PMS 改名这件事将会为研究人员带来更多机会，因为这意味着我们正在转变重心，这非常重要，因为这意味着更多的研究意味着更好的指南，为女性提供更多的治疗方案。但全面来看，我们在女性健康的诊断方面看到了许多进展，特别是在子宫内膜异位症等疾病方面，通常我们的诊断技术相当具有侵入性，我们必须通过手术查看你的腹腔内部。目前有很多研究都在探讨子宫内膜异位症的即时诊断，这将是惊人的。所以我认为这太棒了。
I think when it comes to PMS specifically, there's no specific thing that's on my radar that's going to transform things. But if we can fully establish these different types of PMS, I think that will change how we treat women. I'm really hoping that this new name change means that when women go to their doctors, they will start to feel like they're actually hurt,
我认为具体说到 PMS，我并没有注意到有什么具体的事情能够彻底改变现状。但如果我们能完全确立这些不同类型的 PMS，我认为这将改变我们治疗女性的方式。我真心希望这个新名字的改变意味着，当女性去看医生时，她们开始觉得自己的感受真正得到了倾听，
that the symptoms that they're feeling outside of their reproductive system matters because I think for a long time that was kind of dismissed as it's just not relevant to the conversation. Yeah, no, for sure. I know I said we're going to end on a positive note and we are because I'm going to ask you this question that I think is kind of strange. But it was inspired by this article I saw that was like, this is so strange, but it's like people, with endometriosis. They're like, read it is more attractive. And I know this has been debunked, but I remember reading it and being like, that's so funny that they're like, here's a consolation prize. Yeah, they actually retracted that article because there was so many issues with it. But I'm also like,
她们在生殖系统之外感受到的症状是重要的，因为我认为长期以来，这些都被当作与对话无关的内容而打发掉了。是的，没错，当然。我知道我说过我们要以积极的基调结束，我们确实会这样做，因为我要问你这个我觉得有点奇怪的问题。但它的灵感来自于我看到的一篇文章，内容是这样的：这太奇怪了，但就像患有子宫内膜异位症的人一样。他们就像是，红发更具吸引力。我知道这已经被辟谣了，但我记得当时读到它时觉得，他们说“这是一个安慰奖”，这太搞笑了。是的，他们实际上撤回了那篇文章，因为里面有太多问题。但我也觉得，
to publish a paper, first of all, there's, there was like multiple authors on that. So they all sat around and agreed that this was a great idea. And then they went and got, you know, ethical approval for it. other people had to approve it, that it went through a whole publishing peer review. And no one was like, this is absurd. Also, it's completely irrelevant and also. Irrelevant, yeah. Like, this is April Fools, like, wild. Also, so funny that you couldn't have the emotional intelligence to realize
首先要发表一篇论文，那里有很多作者。所以他们坐在一起，一致认为这是一个好主意，然后他们去获得了道德审批，其他人不得不批准它，它经历了整个发表同行评审的过程。没有人觉得这很荒谬吗？而且这完全不相关，而且。不相关，是的。就像，这是愚人节玩笑吗，太离谱了。而且，真搞笑，你竟然没有同理心去意识到
women's health funding is so limited. They got money to do that study that could have been spent on like a million other things. Yeah. And they were like, are these women hot or not? Yes, that was basically. Hot or not? They were like, can you pay us to play hot or not with a bunch of people who are like experiencing like a life-changing illness?
女性健康资金是如此有限。他们有钱做那个研究，而这笔钱本可以花在其他上百万的事情上。是的。他们当时就像是，这些女性辣不辣？是的，基本上就是这样。辣还是不辣？他们就像是，你能付钱让我们和一群正在经历改变人生疾病的人玩“辣还是不辣”的游戏吗？
Yeah. Please. No. How crazy is that? It's so crazy. And there's been other studies at like within endometriosis and it's like the impact of endometriosis on patients, on the male partners of patients. The impact of their sex life.
是的。拜托。不。这有多疯狂？太疯狂了。还有其他关于子宫内膜异位症的研究，比如子宫内膜异位症对患者、患者男性伴侣的影响。对他们性生活的影响。
That's what I was thinking. I'm like, no one cares. Also, yeah, go away. Leave her alone. Like, she's going through something crazy. Like, that's just insane that it's like that we have all this, there's limited money and we're going to be like, here is the patient. And then it's like, they shift.
这正是我所想的。我想，根本没人关心。而且，是的，走开。别管她。她正在经历疯狂的事情。这简直太疯狂了，资金本来就有限，而我们要说的是：这就是患者。然后他们就转移了话题。
I can almost imagine like they're looking at her and then they're like, their gaze, like, kind of grows out of focus and they like look behind her and they're like you. They're like point to like, how do you feel? And it's like, what? Hello? Like, and this is going to sound so ironic because I'm going to ask. ask you, like, obviously, I'm not, like, yeah, are women with PMOS more attractive? Dr. Hazel? What's your opinion? No, but you mentioned things of like, oh, women with PMOS may have more
我几乎可以想象，他们看着她，然后他们的视线开始失焦，看向她身后，就像是你。他们指着类似……你感觉怎么样？然后就像是，什么？喂？听起来太讽刺了，因为我要问你，显然，我不是……是的，患有 PMS 的女性更有吸引力吗？黑泽尔医生？你有什么看法？不，但你提到了一些事情，比如哦，患有 PMS 的女性可能有更多的
testosterone, androgens, X, Y, Z. Is there anything beneficial or not beneficial, but just like any silver linings for PMOS? Anything that you're like, great, at least I'm maybe better at that, at least I have a lower risk factor for this, anything that's like, again, a consolation prize. So potentially may be able to build more muscle, which is beneficial for many things. Because you might go through the menopause slightly later. I think it's like two years and average later, which is a beneficial thing. And I think something I've been personally thinking about in my own journey is, and I don't think I've been, I've never articulated it publicly because it could go one or two ways. But I think for me personally, it was while I didn't cause my PMOS, the lifestyle I was living wasn't helping.
睾酮、雄激素、X、Y、Z。PMS 有没有什么有益的方面，或者说虽然谈不上益处，但有没有什么积极的意义？有没有什么让你觉得“太好了，至少我在这方面可能更擅长，至少我对这个的风险因素更低”，任何类似于安慰奖的东西？所以可能能够建立更多的肌肉，这对很多事情都有好处。因为你可能会稍微晚一点经历更年期。我觉得平均晚两年左右，这是一件有益的事情。我想我在自己的旅程中一直在思考的一点是——我不认为我……我从未在公开场合表达过这一点，因为这可能会有两个结果。但我认为对我个人而言，虽然我没有导致我的 PMS，但我当时的生活方式并没有提供帮助。
And I think going through the diagnosis made me for the first time in my life actually start putting me first and caring about my sleep, my boundaries, my nutrition, exercise. Like a lot of things that I really enjoy, but I always put other things first. So I think it's helped me to, yeah, put myself first and actually prioritize my health. And while I'm not grateful to have PMOS, I'm grateful for that. Because I believe that I'm actually a much healthier person than the person I was when I first got my diagnosis. And I don't really experience the day-to-day symptoms of PMOS after, you know, I was diagnosed in 2018. after eight years of of going through this. I have regular cycles.
我认为经历诊断过程让我生平第一次真正开始把我自己放在首位，关心我的睡眠、我的边界、我的营养、运动。就像很多我真的很享受，但我总是把其他事情放在首位的事情。所以我认为这帮助我，是的，把自己放在首位，真正优先考虑我的健康。虽然我不感谢自己患有 PMS，但我感谢这段经历。因为我相信我现在的健康状况比刚确诊时要好得多。在2018年确诊后，经过八年的经历，我在日常生活中其实并没有经历 PMS 的症状。我有规律的周期。
I ovulate and I see that. I can help women achieve that and I think that's a really positive thing. It's not, you know, we talk about all of these risk factors. It's not a sentence. This doesn't mean it has to happen. Yeah. And I think that's really how I wanted to end the episode of like this is, you said before, like it can kind of go into, it can be asymptomatic.
我排卵，我能看到这一点。我能帮助女性实现这一点，我认为这是一件非常积极的事情。这不是，你知道的，我们谈论所有这些风险因素。这不是判决。这并不意味着它一定会发生。是的。我认为这确实是我想要结束这一集的方式，就像你之前说的，它可以朝着……它可以变成无症状的。
Aisimatic and I think I read a paper that it can go into remission. almost. And I think we've spoken a lot today about the difficulties in so many areas of life for someone of PMS, from an anecdotal point of view, from a clinician point of view, from a research point of view. And so I think ending on this note of like, yes, terrible experience, yes, hard to have your symptoms recognized. However, like, there is hope. And there are things that maybe you aren't being offered that will assist you. And maybe, maybe the there's not a silver lining, but having any kind of conversation about women's health is helpful and having any conversation about your own health, even if it's maybe not the conversation
无症状，而且我想我读过一篇论文，它几乎可以进入缓解期。我认为我们今天讨论了很多关于 PMS 患者在生活各个领域的困难，从轶事的角度、临床医生的角度、研究的角度。因此，我认为以这种基调结束——是的，糟糕的经历，是的，症状很难被认可。然而，就像，仍然有希望。有些你可能没有得到的帮助会协助你。而且也许，也许没有绝对的好处，但进行任何关于女性健康的对话都是有帮助的，进行任何关于你自身健康的对话，即使它可能不是那种……
you're like maybe you don't want to be having, just brings an awareness that I think has benefits to it. Yeah, I completely agree. And I think I was on Grace Beverly's podcast also. We talked about PCOS at the time and there's a really, there's a soundbite that went really viral. And it was me saying, we say that PCOS can't be cured. It was PCOS at the time. We say PMOS can't be cured, but I'm not so sure anymore. And that clip went really viral because we say it's incurable. But actually, I have seen it in myself and other women, be completely dormant where even your ultrasound features improve.
你可能不想进行的对话，也带来了一种我认为有益的觉醒。是的，我完全同意。我想我也曾上过格蕾丝·贝弗利（Grace Beverly）的播客。我们当时讨论了多囊卵巢综合征（PCOS），有一段在网络上疯传的音频剪辑。那是我在说，我们说 PCOS 是无法治愈的。当时说的是 PCOS。我们说 PMS 是无法治愈的，但我不再那么确定了。那段视频在网上疯传，因为我们一直说它是不可治愈的。但实际上，我在自己和其他女性身上看到过它完全处于休眠状态，甚至你的超声波特征都有所改善。
And I think it's helpful to use that terminology because women need to know that the kind of the state of their PMOS today doesn't mean that it's going to be like that forever. And they need to know that there is a chance for improvement. And there is an absolutely everyone. But the way to get there might be different for another person who has the condition. And, you know, one of the things you mentioned, which we didn't really cover in great detail, is the fertility aspect. And it is more difficult to get pregnant if you've got PMS. That is a fact.
我认为使用这种术语是有帮助的，因为女性需要知道她们今天 PMS 的状态并不意味着它会永远这样下去。她们需要知道有改善的可能。绝对对每个人都是如此。但达到这一目标的途径可能因另一个患有此病的人而异。而且，你知道，你提到的其中一件事我们没有详细讨论，就是生育方面。如果你患有 PMS，怀孕会更困难。这是一个事实。
But that's largely because you're not ovulating every month. there are medications we can use to help. There are fertility techniques. Beyond that, before you get pregnant, we can work to restore ovulation through supplementation, through nutrition, through all those things we spoke about. And I think PMOS compared to a lot of the other women's health conditions, I'm thinking about endometriosis, is probably the most influenced by our lifestyles. It's so influenced by our lifestyles, which is a good thing and a bad thing, but it's a good thing too. Yeah. And I really like that we've also ended on that because I didn't even talk about this. But again, I didn't want to make the conversation to like fertility dominant because I know for some women that's just not something they're thinking about in their early 20s, mid-20s or just not something they want. But I like that you've mentioned that, you know, when I was told I had back at the time, PCOSL like, oh, a third of women can't get pregnant. Like, dun dun dun. And I remember really freaking out about it. And then just, reading and being like, wait, that's, where did they even get that number from?
但这很大程度上是因为你并不是每个月都在排卵。我们有一些药物可以用来协助。也有一些生育技术。除此之外，在你怀孕之前，我们可以通过补充剂、营养补充以及我们谈到的所有这些方法来帮助恢复排卵。而且我认为，与许多其他的女性健康状况（比如我想到了子宫内膜异位症）相比，PMOS可能是受我们生活方式影响最大的一种。它太受我们的生活方式影响了，这既有好的一面也有坏的一面，不过这也是件好事。是的。我真的很喜欢我们最后能以这个话题结束，因为我甚至都没聊到这个。但话说回来，我并不想把对话弄得太偏向生育，因为我知道对于某些女性来说，这并不是她们在20岁出头、20岁中期时会去考虑的事情，或者这根本不是她们想要的东西。但我很高兴你提到了这一点，你知道的，当我以前被告知我有PCOSL时，（他们说）‘哦，三分之一的女性无法怀孕。’就像是，‘咚咚咚’。我记得当时真的吓坏了。然后，读了相关资料后觉得，等等，这……他们这个数字到底是哪来的？
Yeah. Right? Like, that's just this random number. And another thing to say that's completely separate, anytime you see a statistic that's like one third and it's a neat number, like 25%, or like 50%, or it's just such a clean number, you should always be skeptical. Oh my gosh. Always be skeptical because that's, when does that happen?
对吧？这就像是一个随口说出的数字。还有一件事要说，这完全是题外话：任何时候当你看到一个统计数字是诸如三分之一这样整洁的数字，比如25%，或者50%，或者诸如此类非常干净的数字时，你都应该保持怀疑。哦天哪。一定要保持怀疑，因为这怎么可能呢？
And learning more about like, actually, no, like there are so many stories of women who have this condition who never have trouble, do have trouble, find these amazing treatments and clinicians who believe them. Like, there's just so much, the fact that we're having this conversation, like the momentum towards better days for people with this condition is on the up. Like, the velocity at which we're moving towards a better future for people with PMOS is increasing. So thank you for, yeah, confirming that. You're so welcome. Yeah. One more question. I'm sorry. And it has nothing to do with what we talked about. I'm so like enraptured by how you're, how you're explaining this in a way that it's just like so remarkable that I almost forgot to just do the thing that we do in every episode, which is about your 20s. Are you still in your 20s? No, I'm 35.
而且通过更多地了解……实际上，不是的，有太多患有这种疾病的女性的故事，她们从来没有遇到过麻烦，或者遇到过麻烦，但找到了了不起的治疗方法和相信她们的临床医生。所以这里面有太多东西了。我们正在进行这场对话这一事实，表明为患有这种疾病的人争取更好明天的势头正在上升。为了让PMOS患者迎来更美好的未来，我们前进的速度正在加快。所以谢谢你，是的，证实了这一点。不客气。还有一个问题。我很抱歉。这和我们刚才谈论的完全没有关系。我太为你解释问题的方式所折服了，它是如此的出色，以至于我差点忘了做我们在每一期节目里都会做的事情，那就是关于你的20多岁。你现在还在20多岁吗？不，我35岁了。
You're 35. Okay. I actually think that's a great age to ask this question, because you still remember what it's like, but like you're halfway through your 30s now. what is one piece of advice that you wish you had had received in your 20s or you wish you knew in your 20s that our audience should know caveat because we love a caveat as we've spoken about has nothing to do with what we talked about today okay um can i give two oh yes you can give like four you have full of information you can you could just do a whole other episode we would welcome that I, my first one that I've been thinking about lately is I regret not having more fun in my 20s because I think I took my life very seriously to get to the place I wanted to with my career. And I think I still could have done that and still taking myself less seriously.
你35岁了。好的。其实我觉得这是一个问这个问题的绝佳年龄，因为你还记得那时是什么感觉，但你现在已经三十岁过半了。你在20多岁时希望收到但却没收到的一条建议是什么，或者你希望自己在20多岁时就知道的事，是我们的听众应该知道的？（注：因为我们喜欢附加条件，正如我们刚才所说，这和我们今天谈论的话题毫无关系）。好吧，……我能给两个吗？哦，当然可以，你可以给四个，你满肚子的干货，你甚至可以再做整整一期节目，我们非常欢迎。我……我首先想到的是，我后悔在20多岁时没有玩得更开心一点，因为我觉得为了达到事业上想要的高度，我把生活看得太严肃了。我觉得其实我既可以达到那个高度，又可以不用对自己要求那么严肃。
So I think embrace your 20s because you can still have so much fun in your 30s as well. But if there are things that you want to do in your life, be that like buying a house, having a starting family, things can your responsibilities can rack up so enjoy kind of the the fewer responsibilities of your 20s if you can the second thing is it's okay to change your mind and to pivot for a really long time I was kind of stuck on one pathway and I thought everyone would judge me if I changed I left the NHS which is the national healthcare system in the UK a couple of years ago and I was so terrified of judgment and I'm so much happier for it and I've you know dedicated my life now to women's health which was very different to what I was doing before is doing nutrition in the hospital um
所以我认为要拥抱你的20多岁，因为你在30多岁时依然可以玩得很开心。但如果你的人生中有想要做的事情，比如买房、组建家庭，各种责任可能会随之增加，所以如果可以的话，尽情享受20多岁时较少的责任吧。第二件事是：改变主意并转换赛道是完全没问题的。很长一段时间里，我都被困在一条轨道上，以为如果我改变了，每个人都会对我有看法。几年前我离开了NHS（即英国的国家医疗服务体系），当时我太害怕别人的评判了，但我现在为此感到无比快乐。你知道的，我现在把一生奉献给了女性健康，这与我之前在医院做营养学工作时有很大的不同。
and I think for so long we we kind of picture ourselves as this one identity but it's okay if that changes and that might change again so it's okay to not have it all figured out and it's okay to change your mind I love that advice what a beautiful way to end the episode Your book is coming out in paperback very, very soon. Yes, in three days. Three days. That would have already happened when people listen to this. It's called Not Just a Period.
而且我认为在很长一段时间里，我们把自我塑造成了单一的身份，但如果这种身份发生改变也没关系，而且它以后可能还会再变。所以，没有把一切都想清楚是没关系的，改变主意也是没关系的。我太喜欢这个建议了，多么美妙的节目结尾方式。你的书很快就要出平装版了。是的，三天后。三天后。当人们听到这期节目时，书应该已经出版了。书名叫《不仅仅是经期》（Not Just a Period）。
Yeah. I just feel like from the conversation we've had today, I'm going to be picking up a copy, and I'm going to leave a link in the description for you guys too as well. Because I know you might be somebody who feels awkward when people give you compliments, but the way you've explained that is one of the most remarkable kind of conversations that I've been able to have on the podcast. So thank you so much.
是的。我觉得通过我们今天的对话，我会去买一本，我也会在简介里给你们留个链接。因为我知道你可能是一个别人夸奖你会觉得尴尬的人，但你刚才解释的方式，是我在这档播客中经历过的最了不起的对话之一。所以非常感谢你。
Anywhere else that people can find you or where they should go looking for you? Yes. I'm on social media. On Instagram is my main thing. I also do TikTok, but Instagram and TikTok under my name, Dr. Hazel Wallace. I talk mostly about women's health.
还有什么地方人们可以找到你，或者他们应该去哪里寻找你呢？有的。我在社交媒体上。Instagram是我的主阵地。我也玩TikTok，不过在Instagram和TikTok上我都用我的名字，Dr. Hazel Wallace。我主要聊女性健康。
I do a lot of nutrition on there related to women's health as well. And I'm very happy for you to send you DM. Yeah. And yeah, book. Instagram. I will also leave a link to your, I guess, your website or like your clinician page as well so people can check you out. But again, thank you for coming on the podcast. I hope you, the listener has enjoyed. I hope you've learned if you are whatever way through your PMS, PMOS journey, you are sending you a whole lot of love and support and hopefully just the value and the knowledge
我在上面分享很多与女性健康相关的营养知识。我非常欢迎大家给我发私信。是的。还有书、Instagram。我也会留下你的网站或者医生主页的链接，这样大家就可以去了解你啦。但再次感谢你来到本期播客。我希望你——听众朋友们听得开心。我希望无论你处于PMS、PMOS历程的哪个阶段，你都能学到东西，向你发送满满的爱与支持，也希望通过这些价值和知识，
that other people are going through it as well and that there is a lot to be optimistic about. So until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, this is Hayes Davenport. And Sean Clements. We host the podcast, Hollywood Handbook. Every episode we're trying to help our guests improve their careers by mainly focusing on how they can help us improve our careers. The show's famously super accessible so you can easily jump into any of our 650 episodes and understand what's going on.
让你知道其他人也在经历这一切，并且有很多事情是值得乐观的。那么，直到下一次，保重、善良、对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。嘿，我是海斯·达文波特（Hayes Davenport）。还有肖恩·克莱门茨（Sean Clements）。我们是播客《好莱坞手册》（Hollywood Handbook）的主持人。在每一期节目中，我们都试图帮助嘉宾提升他们的职业生涯，主要方法是通过探讨他们如何能帮助我们提升职业生涯。这个节目以超级容易上手而闻名，所以你可以轻松切入我们的650期节目中的任何一期，并且听懂我们在聊什么。
We recommend some of our recent episodes with Ben Stiller, Danny McBride, Riz Ahmed, and and Mary Steenburgeon. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Nick Totoro. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, The Longest Yard, or Spike Lease Black Klansman. And on my new podcast, delivering happiness with Nick Tatourl, I deliver pizza to a new guest. I've shared a slice with everyone from Seth Rollins. What are you doing, my belt?
我们推荐你收听我们最近邀请本·斯蒂勒（Ben Stiller）、丹尼·麦克布莱德（Danny McBride）、里兹·阿迈德（Riz Ahmed）以及玛丽·斯汀伯根（Mary Steenburgen）的节目。在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《好莱坞手册》。我是尼克·托托罗（Nick Turturro）。你可能通过《纽约重案组》（NYPD Blue）、《最长的一码》（The Longest Yard）或斯派克·李的《黑色党徒》（Black Klansman）认识我。在我的新播客《与尼克·托托罗一起传递快乐》（Delivering Happiness with Nick Turturro）中，我会给一位新嘉宾送披萨。我跟形形色色的人分享过披萨，从塞思·罗林斯（Seth Rollins）——你在干什么，我的皮带？
To Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am. And now, we even have more great guests. coming up, including the great John Tuturo. It's called Happiness. Delivering happiness. And many, many more. Open your free High Heart Radio app.
到比尔·伯尔（Bill Burr）。我觉得我从没见过哪个人的精神状态像我一样这么出格。现在，我们还将迎来更多重磅嘉宾，包括伟大的约翰·托托罗（John Turturro）。节目名叫《快乐》。《传递快乐》。还有很多很多。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。
Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Tutoro. And listen now. I'm Hoda Kotbby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb. You know, I'm always searching for inspiration and useful tools to maximize joy. Like when my friend Henry Winkler offered advice to aspiring actors and really anybody hoping to stand out. You're not hired just to fill time and space. You're hired to fill the space with you.
搜索《与尼克·托托罗一起传递快乐》（Delivering Happiness with Nick Turturro）并立即收听。我是霍达·柯布（Hoda Kotb），播客《与霍达·柯布一起探索快乐101》（Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb）的主持人。你知道的，我一直在寻找灵感和实用的工具来最大化快乐。就像我的朋友亨利·温克勒（Henry Winkler）向有志成为演员的人以及任何希望脱颖而出的人提出的建议：你被雇佣不仅仅是为了填补时间和空间。你被雇佣是为了用你自己来填满空间。
Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Our hometown is not a test tube. 90 miles northeast of Nashville, a battle for the future of America, plays out in one small town. Developers with right-wing ties have purchased hundreds of acres of land. We need cities on a shining hill. This is our town. A podcast about what happens when a small town becomes the site of a social experiment and fights back. Guess you didn't move in on a bunch of dumb hillbillies now, did you?
在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《与霍达·柯布一起探索快乐101》（Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb）。我们的家乡不是试管。在纳什维尔东北部90英里处，一场关于美国未来的战役在一个小镇上演。有着右翼背景的开发商购买了数百英亩的土地。我们需要山巅之城。这是我们的家乡。这是一档关于一个小镇成为社会实验场并发起反抗时会发生什么的播客。我想你们搬进来时没料到会遇到一群大老粗吧，是吗？
Listen to Our Town on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Nancy Glass, host of the Burden of Guilt Season 3 podcast. This is a story about a horrendous situation that destroyed two families. It's a scorched earth war that shows just how far someone will. go to get what they want. Cindy said I had to choose between the truth and my family, and I had to choose the truth. Listen to
在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《我们的家乡》（Our Town）。我是南希·格拉斯（Nancy Glass），《罪恶的负担》第三季（The Burden of Guilt Season 3）播客的主持人。这是一个关于摧毁了两个家庭的可怕情况的故事。这是一场焦土政策般的战争，它展现了某人为了得到他们想要的东西会付出多大的代价。辛迪说我必须在真相和我的家庭之间做出选择，我选择了真相。收听
season three of Burden of Guilt on the IHeart Radio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《罪恶的负担》（The Burden of Guilt）第三季，在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人制作。本期节目暂无评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。